Welcome to Programming Throwdown, episode number two, Python. Take it away, Jason. Hey, how's it going? So, how was your day today pretty good pretty good i've been practicing my radio voice oh yeah i've been i've noticed that i turned to youtube for um for learning just about anything like i i wanted to cook snow crab so i went on youtube and i saw how to cook it and then i i cooked it but you know the snow crab has a really tough you know exoskeleton so I couldn't figure out how to get the meat out of the crab so again I turned on YouTube and put in how to eat the snow crab our brains are have been offloaded to Google yeah pretty much anything I
欢迎收听《编程抛掷》第二期，本期主题是 Python。开始吧，Jason。嘿，最近怎么样？今天过得如何？挺好的，挺好的。我一直在练习我的电台嗓音。哦，是吗？我注意到了。我开始在 YouTube 上学习各种东西，比如我想做雪蟹，我就去 YouTube 上看怎么做，然后我就照着做了。但你知道，雪蟹的外骨骼非常坚硬，所以我搞不清楚怎么把蟹肉取出来。于是我又打开 YouTube，搜索“如何吃雪蟹”。我们的大脑已经外包给谷歌了，基本上任何我
need to know how to do I've gone to YouTube it's kind of sad pretty soon it's gonna be like how do I feed myself? How to flush toilet A flush toilet I need to figure out a way to pull my pants up So I did you know I do realize when you write stuff down it's good But you don't remember it like if I write something down I never remember it anymore because like I know it's written down. I don't need to remember it So I guess once you look up how to learn how to eat snow crab it's just always going to be online you're never going to remember yeah that's true i saw a guy on uh wrote a book i think it's called
需要知道怎么做的事情，我都会去 YouTube。这有点可悲。很快就会变成“我该怎么喂饱自己？”、“如何冲厕所？”、“我需要想办法把裤子提起来”。我确实意识到，当你把东西写下来时，这很好，但你记不住它。比如如果我写下什么东西，我就再也记不住了，因为我知道它写在那儿，我不需要记住它。所以我想，一旦你学会了怎么吃雪蟹，它就永远会在网上，你永远不会记住它。是的，确实如此。我看到一个人写了一本书，我想书名是
moonwalking with einstein uh supposedly it's about a guy who uh tried to become like the world or the u.s champion of memorization and i don't know i haven't read the book i just heard about it but uh sounded interesting i'm gonna check that out because i always wanted to have better memory i'm pretty terrible at it oh nice did you see that uh math magician on ted on the ted talk no yeah so this guy uh basically he built himself like a base 300 number system where like he took a bunch of words and he associated them with large numbers. So he can do like really amazing things. Like he's like, you know, give me two six digit numbers and I'll multiply them in my head.
《与爱因斯坦月球漫步》，据说讲的是一个人试图成为世界或美国记忆冠军的故事。我不知道，我没读过那本书，只是听说过，但听起来很有趣。我打算去看看，因为我一直想拥有更好的记忆力，我在这方面很糟糕。哦，不错。你看了 TED 演讲里的那个“数学魔术师”吗？没有。好吧，这家伙基本上给自己建立了一个 300 进制的数字系统，他把一堆单词和大的数字关联起来。所以他能做一些非常惊人的事情。比如他说，给我两个六位数，我能在脑子里把它们乘出来。
And he does it by converting each of the numbers. It might even be more than 300. But he has this whole lexicon and he knows that like slippers is 493 or whatever you know wow and so he converts your number to some really high base and then does the multiplication in his head and then converts that that's a cool parlor trick i guess and really awesome yeah yeah this guy was like i mean he goes around just you know i guess he's a motivational speaker too, or maybe that's all he does, but I guess that's how he makes his living. Wow, well that's pretty cool. Yeah, Mathemagics.
他是通过转换每个数字来做到的。可能甚至不止 300 个。但他有整个词汇表，他知道“拖鞋”是 493 之类的。哇，所以他把你的数字转换成一个非常高的进制，然后在脑子里做乘法，然后再转换回来。我想这是一种很酷的杂耍，真的很棒。是的，这家伙到处……我想他也是个励志演说家，或者也许这就是他的全部工作，但我猜这就是他谋生的方式。哇，那太酷了。是的，数学魔术。
It's called Mathemagics, okay. We'll make sure to link to that video. Oh yeah, yeah, it's a great TED Talk. It's one of the best. Well, you know, it's more like entertainment than the other technology or design. But you tend to say that about almost every TED Talk you watch. This is the best. It's true. It's true. It's like everyone you watch is like, oh, man, this is life-changing.
它叫《数学魔术》，好的。我们一定会附上那个视频的链接。哦，是的，那是一个很棒的 TED 演讲。它是最好的之一。嗯，你知道，它更像是娱乐，而不是其他技术或设计。但你几乎对你观看的每一个 TED 演讲都这么说。这是最好的。这是真的，这是真的。就像你看的每一个都让你觉得，哦，天哪，这改变了人生。
And then you get to the next one. Although, you know, they've been going downhill. Yeah. They franchised. Yeah, they franchised. And now, like, the TEDx talks sometimes take the front page. And you can just tell the quality isn't there, you know. Yep. All right. Well, you want to go and get started with the news yeah sure so what's your uh what's your new story so the uh first news story i had was uh an interesting thing um you know had a little bit
然后你又看下一个。虽然，你知道，它们一直在走下坡路。是的，它们被特许经营了。是的，它们被特许经营了。现在，比如 TEDx 演讲有时会占据头版。你可以看出质量已经不如从前了，你知道的。是的。好吧，你想开始聊聊新闻吗？好的，当然。那么你的新闻故事是什么？我第一个新闻故事是一个有趣的事情，你知道，录制这个播客稍微有点
of delay in recording this podcast so saw this a while ago but i thought it was really interesting that with the new version of the iphone os i, I guess iPhone and iPad and iTouch. But Apple had an upgrade to their JavaScript engine. And I don't know if they started calling it this, or this is what it's always been called, but I guess it's Nitro. I know, I think Google's is V8 or something. So everybody, I guess, has their own cool name for their JavaScript engine. But they made a bunch of performance updates
延迟，所以很久以前就看到了，但我认为非常有趣的是，随着新版 iPhone OS 的发布，我想是 iPhone、iPad 和 iTouch。但苹果对他们的 JavaScript 引擎进行了升级。我不知道他们是否开始这样称呼它，或者它一直都叫这个名字，但我猜是 Nitro。我知道，我想谷歌的是 V8 之类的。所以每个人都有自己很酷的 JavaScript 引擎名称。但他们做了一堆性能更新
to actually improve the speed of JavaScript on their JavaScript engine. But they made a bunch of performance updates to actually improve the speed of JavaScript on their iOS platforms. And it did a really good job and everybody's pretty excited about it. But then people figured out that if you do, if you don't have an iOS device, you won't know this, but you can like bookmark a page, a webpage to your desktop basically
来真正提高 JavaScript 在他们的 JavaScript 引擎上的速度。但他们做了一堆性能更新来真正提高 JavaScript 在他们的 iOS 平台上的速度。它做得非常好，每个人都对此感到非常兴奋。但后来人们发现，如果你没有 iOS 设备，你可能不知道这一点，但你可以把一个页面、一个网页基本上书签到你的桌面上
and run it from there. It's like if you double click on it it's like a hyperlink and it just kind of runs it in the browser oh sorry no no so you can do that um but i was missing some people just have apps that run um basically websites from within the app so they're kind of like an embedded browser or whatever but they're really just like um google's works this way so google's app mostly just you know reference this stuff on internet and if you're using i think the way it works is if you're using the embedded browser instead of using you know natively written ios stuff you don't get the speed ups that they gave to all the other safari stuff so it's kind of an interesting thing that they left that i guess it could be a bug but people are suspecting maybe they did
然后从那里运行它。就像如果你双击它，它就像一个超链接，它只是在浏览器中运行它。哦，抱歉，不，不，所以你可以那样做。但我错过了一些人只是有在应用程序内运行网站的应用程序，所以它们有点像嵌入式浏览器之类的，但它们实际上只是像……谷歌的工作方式就是这样，所以谷歌的应用程序大多只是引用互联网上的这些东西。如果你正在使用，我想它的工作方式是，如果你正在使用嵌入式浏览器，而不是使用原生编写的 iOS 内容，你就得不到他们给所有其他 Safari 内容带来的速度提升。所以这有点有趣，他们留下了这个，我猜这可能是一个错误，但人们怀疑也许他们是故意这样做的。
that on purpose so how does it so the embedded browser i guess it's just a completely different engine than safari well it's supposed to be the same same engine i guess like it's supposed to be a version of embedded safari like within that app oh i see so maybe it has more restrictions right i guess they were saying for possibly for security reasons or something but i thought that was interesting that they yeah that they would you know kind of cripple those interesting because you can do with the html5 stuff you can do a lot of things that you would normally do in a native app apple is always so paranoid about someone writing some app that compromises you know either the hardware itself or even worse like your information or your contacts or
所以它是怎么……嵌入式浏览器，我猜它只是一个与 Safari 完全不同的引擎？嗯，它应该是同一个引擎，我猜它应该是该应用程序内嵌入式 Safari 的一个版本。哦，我明白了，所以也许它有更多的限制？对，我猜他们说可能是出于安全原因之类的，但我认为这很有趣，他们会……你知道，有点削弱那些功能。很有趣，因为你可以用 HTML5 做很多你通常在原生应用程序中做的事情。苹果总是对有人编写一些损害硬件本身，或者更糟糕的是，损害你的信息或联系人或
something like that right so maybe in doing so they left out you know some of these updates i always felt like you know there should be kind of like one browser engine to rule them all you know like and i and there's it's kind of starting to head this way with webkit like webkit webkit is i believe it's on the PlayStation and WebKit is part of, you know, Google Chrome. It's like the engine for that. But yeah, there's no like just generic engine that isn't really tied to like a particular OS or anything like that. Like there's no web engine that just writes to OpenGL or something like that. But I guess that's good because, you know, the competition between them, they drive features from each other so kind of relating spilling transitioning into our next topic um you know
类似的东西的应用程序感到非常偏执，对吧？所以也许在这样做时，他们遗漏了这些更新。我一直觉得，你知道，应该有一种“一个浏览器引擎统治一切”的感觉，你知道，而且它正开始朝着 WebKit 的方向发展，比如 WebKit，我相信它在 PlayStation 上，而且 WebKit 是谷歌 Chrome 的一部分。它是那个引擎。但确实没有一种通用的引擎，不是真正绑定到特定操作系统之类的。比如没有一种直接写入 OpenGL 之类的 Web 引擎。但我猜这很好，因为它们之间的竞争推动了彼此的功能。所以有点关联，过渡到我们的下一个话题，你知道
talking about the new release of firefox 4 and ie9 that uh they've both picked up i guess what was started with chrome i believe with the the tab styles where instead of having the traditional file edit view menu whatever at the top um they just kind of have tabs at the top and they get rid of a lot of that extraneous stuff unless you go looking for it right um so i guess that's good right because if you only had one it just would always stayed kind of what it was yeah that's true that's true i just i feel i think that because you know what they want to do is is tie into the theme of the particular operating system so like in the case of windows if you change your theme they want you know to that theme to be reflected in your browser windows
谈到 Firefox 4 和 IE9 的新版本，它们都采用了我想是从 Chrome 开始的标签页样式，而不是在顶部有传统的“文件、编辑、查看”菜单之类的，它们只是在顶部有标签页，并且去掉了许多无关紧要的东西，除非你去寻找它们，对吧？所以我想这很好，对吧？因为如果你只有一个，它就总是保持原样。是的，那是真的，那是真的。我只是觉得，因为你知道他们想做的是与特定操作系统的主题挂钩，所以在 Windows 的情况下，如果你更改了主题，他们希望该主题反映在你的浏览器窗口中，
which makes sense and so yeah that's fair and but because of that they're kind of tied to um you know those particular os's so there isn't just some generic like right to a frame buffer or something like that yeah um know, web layout engine. So have you downloaded the new Firefox? No, not yet. I want to. Actually, I have the beta on one of my machines, and it seems to run well. I haven't had any crashes or anything with it.
这很有道理，所以是的，这很公平。但正因为如此，它们有点绑定到那些特定的操作系统，所以没有一种通用的、比如写入帧缓冲区之类的东西。是的，嗯，Web 布局引擎。那么你下载新的 Firefox 了吗？没有，还没。我想下载。实际上，我的一台机器上有测试版，它运行得很好。我没有遇到任何崩溃或其他问题。
But one thing I have done is in Google Chrome, I went ahead and changed my YouTube settings so that they use HTML5 instead of Flash. That was pretty cool. They didn't have the, like, seeking in the video. I don't know if maybe I'm using too old a version of Chrome or something, but I have to play a video all the way through, which kind of sucks. But the support is there.
但我做的一件事是在谷歌 Chrome 中，我继续更改了我的 YouTube 设置，以便它们使用 HTML5 而不是 Flash。这很酷。它们没有像视频中的进度条拖动功能。我不知道是不是因为我使用的 Chrome 版本太旧了，但我必须把视频从头播放到尾，这有点糟糕。但支持是有的。
I mean, it's using the ON4, I guess, video codec or on one or something like that. And yeah, it works nice. Works well. Yeah. So I've been using the Firefox four since, yeah, like I guess it's like beta four or beta five or something. It's been a while. And I kind of went upgrade. It was even pretty good back then.
我的意思是，它使用的是 ON4，我猜是视频编解码器，或者 ON1 之类的。是的，它运行得很好。运行得不错。是的。所以我一直在使用 Firefox 4，自从……我想大概是 Beta 4 或 Beta 5 之类的。已经有一段时间了。我升级了。那时它就已经很不错了。
And yeah, it's been nice. I haven't really noticed that much difference to going to the actual, you know, now the full release. But yeah, I've been running it for a while and things have been nice i haven't really noticed that much difference to going to the actual you know now the full release but um yeah i've been running it for a while and things have been nice a couple of the plugins i like to use um haven't been ported over yet i guess but other than that i've had no problems oh nice oh it's called onto onto is the company that google bought and they created their own video codec called vp8 oh yes yeah the interesting thing about it is there's no patents at all i guess it's a completely different um you know um setup or completely different algorithm than you know h264 and uh when google bought it they opened it up completely which is which is really useful because anyone who's done video compression knows or even audio mp3 compression
是的，它一直很好。我并没有真正注意到与现在的正式发布版有什么太大区别。但是的，我已经运行它有一段时间了，一切都很顺利。我并没有真正注意到与现在的正式发布版有什么太大区别，但是的，我已经运行它有一段时间了，一切都很顺利。我喜欢用的一两个插件还没有移植过来，但我没有遇到其他问题。哦，不错。哦，它叫 On2，On2 是谷歌收购的公司，他们创建了自己的视频编解码器叫 VP8。哦，是的，关于它的有趣之处在于根本没有专利。我猜它是一个与 H.264 完全不同的设置或完全不同的算法。当谷歌收购它时，他们完全开放了它，这非常有用，因为任何做过视频压缩的人都知道，甚至音频 MP3 压缩
knows what a nightmare that stuff is with respect to patents and all that. An interesting thing, I've long abandoned Internet Explorer. I've just been burned too many times in the past about terrible experience. But I saw with the new release of Internet Explorer 9, some of the JavaScript performance testing actually showed that Internet explorer 9 is the fastest browser in the west yeah that's interesting i wonder if you know microsoft decided to really
都知道在专利方面那是一场噩梦。有趣的是，我早就放弃了 Internet Explorer。我过去因为糟糕的体验被坑过太多次了。但我看到随着 Internet Explorer 9 的新发布，一些 JavaScript 性能测试实际上显示 Internet Explorer 9 是西方最快的浏览器。是的，这很有趣。我想知道微软是否决定真正
kind of pick it back up because they have just gotten so much flack nobody seems to like internet explorer and remember that thing on the white house where uh somebody asked um hillary clinton if they could have firefox in the white house and she you know she clearly had no idea what firefox meant i mean for her it was like she thought that something was burning you mean the internet it's the internet no no no the thing you use to access web pages yeah the internet so yeah here we'll link to this video i'll put it in the agenda okay but yeah it's a a staffer asked hillary clinton why internet explorer is mandated even though firefox which is free and is security approved and uh her answer was that saving money is complicated
重新捡起来，因为他们受到了太多的抨击。似乎没有人喜欢 Internet Explorer。还记得白宫的那件事吗？有人问希拉里·克林顿他们是否可以在白宫使用 Firefox，她显然不知道 Firefox 是什么意思。对她来说，她以为有什么东西着火了。你是说互联网？是互联网。不，不，你用来访问网页的东西。是的，互联网。所以，我们会链接到这个视频，我会把它放在议程里。好的，但确实有一个工作人员问希拉里·克林顿为什么强制使用 Internet Explorer，尽管 Firefox 是免费的且经过安全认证。她的回答是“省钱很复杂”，
non-answer that's funny all right uh so it looks like you got the next news item here. Yeah, let's see. So former Goldman Sachs employee goes to jail for eight years. And so the deal is this guy, you know, he worked for Goldman Sachs. He's making, let's see here, I think it was, yeah, $400,000 a year to write code for their high-frequency trading applications. And so for people who don't know, there are, you know, many of the financial institutions have computer programmers that go in and write software to trade at extremely high frequency. So what would you say, Patrick, like nanoseconds or something? Yeah, I mean, it's, yeah, sub-millisecond trading times is the stuff I've seen. I'm not an expert by any means, but it's really fast. Like, you know, hundreds of thousands of transactions a minute kind of stuff.
一个非回答。那很有趣。好吧，看起来你有下一个新闻项目。是的，让我们看看。前高盛员工入狱八年。事情是这样的，这家伙在高盛工作，他赚了……让我们看看，我想是每年 40 万美元，为他们的高频交易应用程序编写代码。对于那些不知道的人，许多金融机构都有计算机程序员，他们编写软件进行极高频率的交易。那么你会怎么说，Patrick，比如纳秒之类的？是的，我的意思是，我见过亚毫秒级的交易时间。我绝不是专家，但它真的很快。比如每分钟几十万笔交易之类的。
Yeah, insanely fast. I think they do arbitrage, but they also speculate, right? You know, in that short amount of time. Yeah. And so this guy is writing the software that, you know, essentially becomes an arms race. You know, someone has this kind of software and then he writes this, this you know software that learns to exploit their software and so on and so forth um they're paying him 400 000 a year and uh he decided that he was going to take his software over to a small company that they offered to double i think double his salary um so uh he
是的，快得离谱。我想他们做套利，但他们也进行投机，对吧？在那么短的时间内。是的。所以这家伙编写的软件本质上变成了一场军备竞赛。有人有这种软件，然后他编写了学习利用他们软件的软件，以此类推。他们付给他每年 40 万美元，他决定把他的软件带到一家小公司，他们提出薪水翻倍，我想是翻倍。所以他
tried sneaking the software into that company he got caught and he got yep eight years of federal jail time which is serious business straight out of office space oh man okay uh yeah we'll just move on um so don't steal code ladies and gentlemen yeah yeah so this is interesting right for for several reasons's, you know, he didn't actually make any money off of it or steal any money. So in that respect, it seems like eight years is extremely serious. You know, but this goes to show that, you know, people in companies take this stuff extremely seriously and it's your responsibility you know as a as a software engineer to uh to you know be ethical and these types and not try and pull these types of shenanigans yeah definitely that's hmm i mean i guess it's good that it shows that you know he
试图把软件偷偷带进那家公司，结果被抓住了，被判了八年联邦监狱监禁，这是严肃的事情，就像《办公空间》里的情节。哦，天哪。好吧，我们继续吧。所以女士们先生们，不要窃取代码。是的，这很有趣，对吧？出于几个原因，他实际上并没有从中赚到钱或偷走任何钱。所以在这方面，八年看起来非常严重。但这表明，公司里的人非常认真地对待这些事情，作为一名软件工程师，你有责任保持道德，不要试图搞这些花招。是的，绝对是。嗯，我想这很好，因为它表明他
didn't get off easy for doing something that's you know stealing essentially the livelihood of the business not that i'm a big defender of the banks, but still. Yeah, yeah, exactly. It's wrong. Yeah, definitely. Yeah. I mean, you can definitely get hit hard. So if anyone's thinking of,
并没有因为做这种本质上窃取企业生计的事情而轻易脱身。并不是说我是银行的坚定捍卫者，但仍然。是的，完全正确。这是错误的。是的，绝对是。我的意思是，你肯定会受到重创。所以如果有人在想，
if anyone out there works for Goldman Sachs and is thinking of trying to pull a stunt like this, this dude got eight years in federal penitentiary. If that's the average salary, $400,000 a year at Goldman Sachs, please donate to our show, Programming Throwdown at gmail.com. Yeah, we'll set up a PayPal account just for you, Mr. Goldman Sachs employee. Yeah. Oh, man.
如果外面有人在高盛工作，并且想尝试搞这种把戏，这家伙在联邦监狱里待了八年。如果那是平均工资，高盛每年 40 万美元，请捐赠给我们的节目，Programming Throwdown at gmail.com。是的，我们会专门为你设立一个 PayPal 账户，高盛员工先生。哦，天哪。
Those guys work crazy hours, and they've gone through a tough spat, so don't envy them. Yeah. No, this is hard times for everybody, and I'm sure those people are no exception. Right. So I have another news article. Do you have one now, or do you want to go back and forth? No, I think we're done with mine.
那些家伙工作时间很疯狂，而且他们经历了一段艰难时期，所以不要羡慕他们。是的。不，这对每个人来说都是艰难时期，我相信这些人也不例外。好的。所以我还有另一篇新闻文章。你现在有一篇吗，还是我们想来回交流？不，我想我的已经说完了。
Okay. So this is kind of interesting. This is from NewsWise. And this guy wants to start investigating. It's a professor, a young professor, and he wants to investigate green computing or energy-efficient computing. And so, you know, programming languages, they usually serve, you know, one of several purposes. One is, you know, let's say efficiency, like in the case of C or C++, where you just really need to push data through or do some, you know, expensive computation.
好的。这很有趣。这是来自 NewsWise 的。这家伙想开始调查。他是一位教授，一位年轻的教授，他想调查绿色计算或节能计算。所以，你知道，编程语言通常服务于几个目的之一。一个是效率，比如 C 或 C++，你需要真正推动数据或进行一些昂贵的计算。
Or they work on the, you know Or they try and maximize productivity. So Python, one of the languages that we'll be talking about later today, is sort of focused on productivity and trying to save your time and be programmer efficient, if you will. No one really that I know of has up until now looked into this energy efficient computing. So this is really quite interesting. And as we're moving to mobile devices and in general, as being green is kind of in right
或者他们致力于……或者他们试图最大化生产力。所以 Python，我们今天晚些时候会谈到的语言之一，有点专注于生产力和试图节省你的时间，如果你愿意的话，提高程序员效率。据我所知，到目前为止，还没有人研究过这种节能计算。所以这真的很有趣。随着我们转向移动设备，总的来说，作为“绿色”现在很流行，
now, this was, you know, this has Wynn written all over it from a professor standpoint. So he got some really nice grant money. And I thought this was pretty cool, pretty cool stuff. I like to see kind of what comes out of it. That's interesting. So, you know, in compiler optimization, you can compile for code size, compile for speed, compile for memory footprint. Now I guess you're going to have a compile for energy. Yeah, I mean, what does that mean? I mean, I guess in a superficial sense, you try to limit the number of instructions.
这从教授的角度来看，简直是赢定了。所以他得到了一些非常好的拨款。我认为这很酷，非常酷的东西。我喜欢看看会有什么结果。这很有趣。所以，在编译器优化中，你可以为代码大小编译，为速度编译，为内存占用编译。现在我想你将不得不为能源编译。是的，我的意思是，那意味着什么？我的意思是，我想在表面意义上，你试图限制指令的数量。
But then even then, I mean, you know, you might try to get more cache hits. Maybe that then even then i mean you know you might try to get more cache hits maybe that saves energy i'm not really even sure but those same things that would you would do already just to improve performance i guess if you're willing to sacrifice this would be a hard thing to do but if you're willing to sacrifice you know kind of the deterministic execution speed you could you know do things like pausing and collecting up all the disks accesses or ram access accessing at one time and kind of do them all in a bundle even if it means waiting to do it but it seems like they kind of already try to do that yeah it's hard to think of things that are energy efficient but not but that don't increase productivity um trying to think of
但即便如此，我的意思是，你可能会尝试获得更多的缓存命中。也许那样……即便如此，我的意思是，你可能会尝试获得更多的缓存命中，也许那样能节省能源，我甚至不确定。但那些你为了提高性能已经会做的事情，如果你愿意牺牲……这将是一件很难做到的事情，但如果你愿意牺牲确定性的执行速度，你可以做一些事情，比如暂停并收集所有的磁盘访问或 RAM 访问，一次性完成，把它们打包在一起，即使这意味着要等待。但看起来他们似乎已经尝试那样做了。是的，很难想到节能但又不降低生产力的事情。我试着想
something off the top of my head. I mean, I've heard before, this is at a much, much lower level, but the whole idea, which is extremely fascinating, and if you want a time sink of black hole of your effort for the next couple of days, look into reversible computing. Really? I've never even heard of that. There's this whole, and I'll quickly show how much I don't know to anybody listening who knows anything about this field, um i guess it comes down to kind of information theory that one of the reasons why we're hitting an upper limit on the density of um you know
一些东西。我的意思是，我以前听说过，这处于一个非常非常低的水平，但整个概念，非常迷人，如果你想在接下来的几天里浪费你的精力，去研究一下可逆计算。真的吗？我甚至从来没听说过。有整个……我会很快向任何对此领域有所了解的听众展示我有多无知，我想这归结为信息论，我们触及密度上限的原因之一，
transistors and and doing stuff in our chips and is that when you do an operation so like an and right so you do one and one is one. One and zero is zero. But zero and one is also zero. So you're losing some information there. That operation is not reversible. Neither is an or. Most of the operations are not reversible. A not is reversible, right?
晶体管和在芯片中做事情，是因为当你执行一个操作时，比如一个“与”门，1 和 1 是 1。1 和 0 是 0。但 0 和 1 也是 0。所以你在那里丢失了一些信息。那个操作是不可逆的。或者也不是。大多数操作都是不可逆的。“非”是可逆的，对吧？
Because you just nod it back. So that you don't actually lose any information. So the idea is that when you destroy information, that is kind of somehow related to energy. And so when you lose information, you know, kind of destroy it, you're going to expend energy. That information has to go somewhere
因为你只是把它反转回来。所以你实际上并没有丢失任何信息。所以这个想法是，当你销毁信息时，这在某种程度上与能量有关。所以当你丢失信息，销毁它时，你就会消耗能量。这些信息必须去某个地方，
and it dissipates into heat or whatever. And so the idea with reversible computing is to say if you can kind of keep track of all these sets of operations and be able to at some level undo it and you kind of accumulate this log of everything um that you'll run more efficient and then at some point you could kind of choose to get rid of all the information all the bits you don't need and kind of exude power at that point on your terms and your choosing uh it's very it gets very weird and the information theory gets crazy
它会消散成热量之类的。所以可逆计算的想法是说，如果你能跟踪所有这些操作集，并且能够在某种程度上撤销它，你就会积累所有东西的日志，你会运行得更高效。然后在某个时候，你可以选择摆脱所有你不需要的信息和位，并在那个时候按你的条件和选择散发能量。这非常……它变得非常奇怪，信息论变得疯狂。
it gets tied in with like you know black holes you just blew my head black holes destroyed do they destroy information or not um yeah it oh and then there's the maxwell's damon oh i guess there's like several so you're saying there's a bunch of instructions that don't destroy information and those cost less energy or cost no energy so i don't the way i've seen it explained is with billiard balls so you can make an end gate out of billiard balls but you can also make um that that kind of you end up with so if you do an and you end up with the output of the and and also like another bit that represents to distinguish between the 0, 1, 1, 0 case. So you end up with this extra bit of information that kind of allows you to know how you got to
它与黑洞之类的东西联系在一起。你刚才让我的头都大了。黑洞会销毁信息吗？是的，哦，还有麦克斯韦妖。哦，我想有几个……所以你是说有一堆不销毁信息的指令，那些消耗更少的能量或不消耗能量？我看到的解释是用台球。你可以用台球做一个“与”门，但你也可以做一个……你最终会得到……如果你做一个“与”，你最终会得到“与”的输出，还有另一个位来区分 0,1 和 1,0 的情况。所以你最终得到了这个额外的信息位，它让你知道你是如何得到
having the zero, whether it was from two zeros, a 0, 1, or a 1, 0. And so you kind of record, or maybe you end up, yeah, maybe you end up with three bits. Somehow you end up tagging along that extra information that allows you to reverse the computation. like i said it's a time sink i don't really understand it and i probably just made a bunch of people who know what they're talking about uh realize how stupid i am but that's okay no i think you just made them angry which is okay that's one of the goals yes if we can't teach you something we at least want to piss you off write write to us and tell us how we messed it up and maybe we'll get you on the show and have you explain it to us for reals. Yeah, that's right. If you hate us, give us five stars.
那个 0 的，无论是从两个 0，一个 0,1，还是一个 1,0。所以你记录下来，或者也许你最终……是的，也许你最终得到了三个位。不知何故，你最终带上了那个允许你反转计算的额外信息。就像我说的，这是一个时间黑洞。我不太明白，我可能刚刚让一堆知道自己在说什么的人意识到我有多蠢，但没关系。不，我想你只是让他们生气了，这没关系，这是目标之一。是的，如果我们不能教你什么，我们至少想让你生气。写信告诉我们我们哪里搞砸了，也许我们会请你上节目，让你为我们真正解释一下。是的，没错。如果你讨厌我们，给我们五颗星。
That's the worst rating you can give us on iTunes. So I think also not just extending you know, in this particular article they're talking about making energy Java, which is an extension of Java that would somehow be more energy efficient. But also more different languages, I think, would be inherently more energy efficient, provided
那是你在 iTunes 上能给我们的最差评分。所以我认为不仅仅是扩展……在这个特定的文章中，他们谈论的是制造“能源 Java”，这是 Java 的一个扩展，它会以某种方式更节能。但我认为，更多的不同语言本质上也会更节能，前提是
that you're running on a multi-core system. And so, for example, a GPU per watt or whatever can deliver a lot more computation than a CPU. But it has limitations because, for example, all the cores in a GPU have to execute the same instruction at the same time. So if you have a programming language or a construct that sort of helps guide you to work within those limitations, then maybe something that is very highly multi-threaded could you know allow you to save energy because that's really where a lot of energy is wasted and is is in the bottleneck where you have this huge bank of memory but then only one small
你在多核系统上运行。例如，每个 GPU 的瓦特数或任何东西可以提供比 CPU 多得多的计算能力。但它有局限性，因为例如，GPU 中的所有核心必须同时执行相同的指令。所以如果你有一种编程语言或结构，它能帮助引导你在这些限制内工作，那么也许某种高度多线程的东西可以让你节省能源，因为那确实是浪费大量能源的地方，是在瓶颈处，你有巨大的内存库，但一次只能在单核处理器上使用其中一小部分。我想这就是为什么我们要研究，对吧？所以如果我们知道答案，就不需要研究它了。是的，完全正确。所以这是一篇关于 Brainiac 的新闻文章，是关于《俄勒冈之旅》的起源。我不知道你是否有这个，或者这只是我们在加拿大有的东西，但在加拿大，我们有这些 Apple II，你知道，学校里有计算机，我们会跳上这些 Apple II 玩《俄勒冈之旅》和《Odell Lake》，你们也玩过吗？是的，在某种程度上，是的，我们玩过。哦，天哪，是的，所以这只是美好的回忆，比如《卡门·圣地亚哥在哪里》。哦，是的，那个太棒了。这篇文章谈论的只是《俄勒冈之旅》，它来自哪里，实际上是由一些老师编程和设计的，他们
tiny sliver of it can be used at one time on a single core processor. I guess that's why we have research, right? So if we knew the answer, we wouldn't need to research it. Yeah, exactly. So this is a news article on Brainiac, and it was on the origins of Oregon Trail. And I don't know if you had this, or if this was just something we had in Canada, but in Canada, we had uh uh these apple 2es you know there was like a computer uh computer i don't know i guess using period in school and we'd jump on these apple 2es and play oregon trail and odell lake and did you guys do that yeah at some extent yeah we did oh man yeah so it's just good memories like where in the world is carmen san diego oh yeah that one was fantastic and uh this article is talking about just Oregon Trail where it came from is actually programmed or and uh designed by um um by some teachers who
碰巧非常极客，喜欢编码，他们受到“选择你自己的冒险”书籍的启发。关于《俄勒冈之旅》，它是一个完整的模拟，我的意思是，它非常以自我为中心，不像其他马车经过你之类的，但你知道，在这个意义上，你沿着这条小路旅行，你必须处理寻找食物，环境会影响狩猎场之类的。它几乎是一个完整的模拟，这使得它非常有趣，这么古老的东西，竟然能有那么强大的功能。是的，很多人似乎都记得那个。
just happen to be really geeky and into coding and uh they were inspired by choose your own adventure books and uh it was really you know the thing about oregon trail is it's a complete simulation i mean it's you know it's very uh egocentric um it's not like other wagons are passing you by or anything like that um but you know in the sense that you know you're traveling along this trail and you're having to deal with hunting for food and the uh environment can influence you know the hunting grounds and things like that. It's almost a complete simulation, which makes it just very interesting that something this old, that old, could be that powerful. Yeah, a lot of people seem to remember that.
我们这个年纪的大多数人都记得玩过它。“你得了痢疾。”是的，没错。有趣的是，事实上，新闻文章有一个标题，或者有一个图表，图表清楚地说明 Nicole 患有痢疾。你可以去 virtualapple.org。我不知道你有没有去过那个网站。哦，是的，太棒了。www.virtualapple.org。它有很多 Apple IIe 游戏。我不确定。它说它有版权，
Most people our age kind of remember playing it. You've got dysentery. Yeah, that's right. It's funny, in fact, the news article has a caption, or has a figure, and the figure clearly states that Nicole has dysentery. And you can go on virtualapple.org. I don't know if you've ever been on the site. Oh, yeah, it's great. www.virtualapple.org. And it has a number of, you know, Apple IIe games. I'm not sure. It says that it's copyrighted,
保留所有权利等。我不确定它的合法性。它看起来很合法。看起来他们没有做任何违法的事情。也许他们有许可。我不确定。《俄勒冈之旅》就在上面。是的，没错。
all rights reserved, etc. I'm not sure what the legality of it is. It seems legitimate. It doesn't seem like they're doing anything illegal. Maybe they have permissions. I'm not sure. Oregon Trail is on there. Yeah, that's right.
《俄勒冈之旅》在上面。《Odell Lake》也在上面。它实际上是一个 Java 小程序，所以有人用 Java 构建了一个 Apple IIe 模拟器，就在浏览器中运行。它甚至可能是一个浏览器插件。有趣。好吧，我现在不想打开它，我最终会把小路上的事情搞砸，我最终会搞砸我们的 Skype 连接，或者……天哪，抓住那只鹿，抓住那只鹿，抓住那只鹿。我本应该涉水过河的。哦，是的，记得有一个……是的，我不知道，没关系，好的，抱歉，你继续。是的，我的意思是，九岁的时候，我们什么都不知道。所以有一条河，它就像……我不知道
Oregon Trail is on there. Odell Lake is on there. It's actually a java applet so someone built an apple 2e emulator in java and uh runs right there in the browser it actually might even be a browser plug-in interesting well i don't want to open this up right now i'll end up messing up on the trail i'll end up messing up our skype connection and or man get that deer get the deer get the deer i should have fjorded the river oh yeah remember there was one where uh yeah i guess i had no idea never mind okay sorry go ahead yeah i mean at nine years old you know we had no idea so there's this river it was like uh i don't
斯瓦尼河，我不记得了，但它大概有 20 英尺深，我就想，哦，是的，直接涉水过去，直接走过去，你知道，然后你就失去了一切。你被冲走了。你在课间休息时哭泣，是的。好的，我们是书呆子。好吧。所以我的今日工具是一个很酷的分布式版本控制
know swanee river i don't remember but it was it was something like like 20 feet deep and i was like oh yeah just forward it just walk across you know, and then you lose everything. You have been washed away. You end up crying at recess, yeah. Okay, we're nerds. Alright. So my tool of the day is a cool distributed version control
系统，所以，你知道，在 Git、Mercurial 的行列中，还有哪些大的？还有几个其他的，但……Subversion，嗯，Subversion 不是分布式的。哦，那是对的。所以……分布式系统，但这个很有趣。所以我有点喜欢，并且一直在努力做得更好……现在已经不是新年了，但我过去几年的半新年决心一直是更好地在家/个人事务中进行版本控制。Subversion 有一些工具可以让你这样做，但它并没有真正设置为那样。分布式系统的好处是
system, so, you know, in the vein of Git, Mercurial, what are the other big ones? There's a couple other ones but um subversion well subversion is not distributed though oh that's right so um so distributed ones but this one's interesting so the thing i kind of like and i've been trying to do better about um it's not really the new year anymore but my semi new year's resolution for the last couple of years has been to do better about version control at home slash for personal stuff. And one of the nice things Subversion has some tools will let you do that, but it's not really set up to do that. The nice thing about the
它总是那样的，你可以在本地机器上拥有一个存储库。然后在某个时候，你与其他人合并存储库，他们之前可能拥有你的版本，然后他们分开了，四处移动。没有一个中央存储库是每个人都引用的存储库。所以这有点让人困惑，让它变得有点困难。我绝不是版本控制方面的专家，更不用说分布式版本控制了。但 Fossil 很好，因为它是一个单一的可执行文件，你把它放在你的路径中，你就可以……所以我用它在 Windows 上，你能够签入和签出东西，它背后没有复杂的系统。我以前用过 Mercurial 和 Git，
distributed stuff is that that's kind of how it always is, is you can just have a repository on your local machine. And then at some point, you kind of merge repositories with other people who could have previously, you know, had a version from yours and they kind of split up and move throughout. There isn't a one central repository that's the repository
它们很好，但它们有点……纠缠在一起，它们做了更多的事情。这个，你知道，我猜它可能做了很多，但它真的很简单，只是一个可执行文件，非常基础。我一直在用它在我的本地计算机上做版本控制，用于我应该一直使用它但一直没有真正做的事情。这看起来不错。我在使用 GitHub 的 Git 时遇到了很多痛苦。我现在已经到了使用 Tortoise Git 进行 Git 提交的地步，因为我更喜欢那个界面，它与资源管理器集成在一起，所有这些好东西。但我必须使用 Git GUI，这是 Git 自带的一个单独程序，来进行推送。它与我……我从来没能让 SSH 密钥
everybody refers to. So that kind of confuses people, makes it a little bit hard. And I'm not an expert by any means on version control, much less distributed version control. But Foss fossil is nice because it's a single executable um that you you put in your path and you're able to so i use it on windows and you're able to like check stuff in and out and there isn't a complicated you know system behind it i've used mercurial before and get to some extent
在 Tortoise Git 中正常工作，我似乎在 Git 上遇到了太多麻烦。所以这个看起来很棒，绝对要去看看。是的，所以……就像我说的，我不是专家，但我喜欢它，它有在内部设置服务器的能力，所以比如我可以把它打开，然后网络上的其他人可以下载我的存储库或类似的东西并克隆它。所以它很好，我喜欢它，值得一看。那么你会说分布式版本控制系统和普通版本控制系统之间有什么区别？我现在真的会让人们生我的气，测验模式。我真的会让人们生我的气，因为我……我很惭愧地说我不是非常
and they're they're nice but they're kind of, you know, tangled up in, they do a lot more. This, you know, I guess it probably does a lot, but it's really simple, just, you know, one executable, really basic. And I've been using it to do, you know, version control on my local computer for stuff that I should have been always using stuff for and just haven't really been doing. This looks nice. I've had so much grief with Git using GitHub. I've gotten to the point now where I use the Tortoise Git to do a Git commit because I like that interface better and it integrates with Explorer and all that good stuff. But then I have to use the Git GUI, which is a separate program that comes with Git, to do the push. It has something to do with I i could never get the ssh key
精通我的版本控制知识。不，我也不是。所以我理解的是 Subversion、CVS，它们有点基于中央存储库的想法。有一个位置是主服务器。你，根据你的工作流程和系统的确切性质，签出文件或获取存储库副本，在自己的机器上工作，然后提交回那个中央存储库。所以你可以像锁定那里的文件一样，处理它们，然后带着更改重新提交它们，然后其他人检查那个存储库，可以拉取更改，做他们的更新，修复东西，无论什么。分布式版本控制系统的区别在于，某些操作在这些其他系统中很难做，
working right in tortoise git enough i've just it seems like i just have so much trouble with git so this this looks awesome definitely going to check this one out yeah so i you know like i said i'm not an expert but i liked it and it has the ability to set up a server within it so like you know i could put it open and then um somebody else on my network could you know download my repository or whatever and clone it so it's nice i like it it's worth looking into so what would you say is the difference between a distributed version control system and just a regular version control system i'm gonna really get people mad at me now quiz mode i'm really gonna get people mad at me because i I'm ashamed to say I'm not very
变得非常容易做。分支，分支真的很容易做。并且在同一时间存在代码的多个版本，比如八个不同的并行路径同时进行，并不是什么大问题。你做的方式，甚至在你的计算机上，拥有多个版本也很容易，因为没有中央存储库。你可以有一个，对吧？比如你和我可以说，哦，我们要托管在 GitHub 上。那是我们的官方存储库，但实际上它只是存储库的另一个版本，每个人的版本都和任何人的版本一样重要或权威。所以例如，我可以把我的更改推给你，你可以在你的存储库中进行更改，然后你可以把它们推送到 GitHub 服务器。我不必把它们推送到 GitHub
polished on my knowledge of version control. No, me neither. So the way I understand it is Subversion, CVS, they kind of work on the idea of a central repository. There's one location that is the master. And you, depending on your workflow and the exact nature of the system you check out files or you know get a copy of repository work on your own and you submit back to that central repository so you can like lock files there you know work on them and then resubmit them back with changes and then other people go check against that can pull changes um you know do their updates fix stuff whatever um the difference with a distributed version control system uh is that certain operations which are
服务器，你得到它们，把它们带下来，我们可以互相分享并混合这些更改，因为没有一个每个人都必须从中下载的分支。哦，有趣。在 Subversion 中，如果你要创建一个新分支，你必须去主服务器说我想要你拆分并制作。
complicated to do um in one of these others are become very easy to do like branches branches are really easy to do um and having multiple versions of the code existing at one time, like, you know, eight different kind of parallel paths going at one time isn't really a big issue. And the way that you do and even on your computer, having multiple versions is easy because there is no central repository. You can have one, right? Like you and I could say, oh, we're going to, you know, host, you know, on GitHub. That's our, you know, official repository official repository but in reality it's just another version of the repository and everybody's is just as important or um authoritative as anybody else's and so for instance i could um push to you my changes you can make them in your repository and then you could push them up to the github server um i don't have to push them to the github
在其他系统中变得非常容易，比如分支，分支真的很容易实现，而且同时拥有代码的多个版本，比如同时有八种不同的并行路径，这并不是什么大问题。你操作的方式，甚至在你的电脑上，拥有多个版本都很容易，因为没有中央仓库。你可以有一个，对吧？比如你和我可以说，我们要托管在 GitHub 上。那是我们的官方仓库，但实际上它只是仓库的另一个版本，每个人的版本都和其他人的一样重要或具有权威性。因此，举个例子，我可以把我的更改推送到你那里，你可以在你的仓库中进行更改，然后你可以把它们推送到 GitHub 服务器，我不必非得把它们推送到 GitHub
server you get them bring them back down we can can share with each other and co-mingle those because there is no one branch that everybody has to come down from Oh interesting In Subversion, if you were to create a new branch, you would have to go to the master server and say I want you to split and make
服务器，你获取它们，把它们下载下来，我们可以互相分享并合并这些更改，因为没有一个每个人都必须从中下载的分支。哦，真有趣。在 Subversion 中，如果你想创建一个新分支，你必须去主服务器说我想要你拆分并创建一个
a new branch for me whereas it sounds like with this system you're making your own branch and you don't need the server's permission and like with this system, you're making your own branch and it has nothing, you don't need the server's permission. And the server doesn't even know you have your own branch. Right, right. And I can make multiple revisions, multiple check-ins against myself. For those to you, you merge some changes, do additional, and then you merge back to the quote unquote, you know, central, you know, authoritative, whatever base. And then if you actually look at the, it's kind of cool when you look at the, you know, authoritative, whatever, base. And then if you actually look at the – it's kind of cool.
对我来说是一个新的分支，而听起来用这个系统，你可以创建自己的分支，不需要服务器的许可，就像这个系统一样，你创建自己的分支，它什么都没有，你不需要服务器的许可。而且服务器甚至不知道你有自己的分支。对，对。我可以针对我自己进行多次修订，多次签入。对于你们来说，你合并一些更改，进行补充，然后你合并回所谓的，你知道，中央的，你知道，权威的，无论什么基础。然后如果你真的看那个，当你看到那个，你知道，权威的，无论什么基础时，这有点酷。然后如果你真的看那个——这有点酷。
When you look at the, you know, version history, you see all these merges and splits. And you can do things that would just cause a nightmare under most repositories. Oh, nice. That's good stuff. I'm definitely going to check out this also. That's awesome. So, yeah, I guess my – What is your tool of the week?
当你看到那个，你知道，版本历史时，你会看到所有这些合并和拆分。你可以做一些在大多数存储库下会导致噩梦的事情。哦，不错。那是好东西。我肯定也会去看看这个。太棒了。所以，是的，我想我的——你这周的工具是什么？
My tool of the day, or I guess of the bi-week, isn't quite as cool. Oh, my gosh. Sorry. My tool doesn't have fossils or tiger blood, sadly. But it is actually extremely useful. I've been using it for a while now and I think it's fantastic. It's called Unison. Specifically, I'm talking about the Unison File Synchronizer. What this does is you give it two directories and they could either be local directories or one can
我今天的工具，或者我想是双周的工具，没那么酷。哦，天哪。抱歉。我的工具很遗憾没有化石或老虎血。但它实际上非常有用。我已经用了一段时间了，我觉得它太棒了。它叫 Unison。具体来说，我说的是 Unison 文件同步器。它的作用是，你给它两个目录，它们可以是本地目录，或者其中一个可以是
be an FTP, one could be an SSH location on a remote server. And it essentially compares the two directories recursively and then gives you a list of changes. And it can do this in a variety of different ways. It can compare the dates. It can actually compare the content. And in the end, it presents you with this list. If one of the files is newer on one of the directories than the other, it will automatically suggest to move the newer file over to the older one and vice versa. Otherwise, if it can't figure it out, either because it doesn't have access to one of the dates
FTP，或者远程服务器上的 SSH 位置。它本质上是递归地比较这两个目录，然后给你一个更改列表。它可以用多种不同的方式来做这件事。它可以比较日期。它实际上可以比较内容。最后，它会向你展示这个列表。如果其中一个目录中的文件比另一个目录中的文件新，它会自动建议将较新的文件移动到较旧的文件中，反之亦然。否则，如果它无法弄清楚，要么是因为它无法访问其中一个日期
or it gets confused or something like that, or if both files have been modified since the last time you ran Unison, then it will put up a little question mark and you can make the call on do you want to diff these two files manually and merge them together that way or do you want to just pick one file or the other in general it's great for synchronizing your usb stick so if you have a bunch of docs or a bunch of files on your USB stick, you don't want to run the risk of losing the USB stick and losing all of that data permanently. So you can run this Unison program and put your USB stick and then put a directory on your hard drive and it will
或者它感到困惑或类似的事情，或者如果两个文件自上次运行 Unison 以来都被修改过，那么它会弹出一个小问号，你可以决定是手动比较这两个文件并将它们合并在一起，还是只选择其中一个文件。总的来说，它非常适合同步你的 U 盘，所以如果你在 U 盘上有一堆文档或一堆文件，你不想冒丢失 U 盘并永久丢失所有数据的风险。所以你可以运行这个 Unison 程序，然后放入你的 U 盘，再放入你硬盘上的一个目录，它就会
sort of keep everything in sync. Very cool, very cool. I've actually been looking for something like this, not quite like this. This is interesting that ours are almost tied together almost like version control for usb stick but uh that's funny yeah i almost made the same thing but um so i don't know if you use dropbox before but dropbox you know uses their server in the cloud to kind of take data from a folder store it there and also push it out to other folders kind of keeping them all linked up together um right and i've then looking for a version that I could host like in my home network and do the same thing across all my computers so like keep all of my my documents together and there's no you can do it with Dropbox
把所有东西保持同步。非常酷，非常酷。我其实一直在找这样的东西，不完全是这样。这很有趣，我们的几乎联系在一起，几乎就像 U 盘的版本控制，但呃，这很有趣，是的，我几乎做了同样的事情，但是嗯，所以我不知道你以前是否用过 Dropbox，但 Dropbox，你知道，使用他们在云端的服务器来从文件夹中获取数据，存储在那里，并将其推送到其他文件夹，把它们都链接在一起，嗯，对，我一直在寻找一个版本，我可以在我的家庭网络中托管，并在我所有的电脑上做同样的事情，所以就像把我所有的文档放在一起，没有你可以用 Dropbox 做
like that'll work fine but there's a limit to their free size and you have to pay if you want more and I kind of just want something that you know I don't care about how much data is thinking across and I found one but they're not in release yet and I haven't tried it yet but it's called sparkle share and that's kind of that it doesn't help you with like USB sticks like you're talking about but keeping you know multiple computers in your household synced like I'm constantly moving from my desktop to my laptop and I would love to be able to just know that all the files are on both and not have to worry about, oh, that's on my laptop. I need it on my desktop.
那样做没问题，但他们的免费空间有限，如果你想要更多就得付费，我只是想要一些你知道的，我不在乎有多少数据在同步，我找到了一个，但他们还没有发布，我还没试过，但它叫 Sparkle Share，这有点像，它对你说的 U 盘没帮助，但保持你家里多台电脑同步，比如我经常从台式机换到笔记本电脑，我很想能够知道所有文件都在两台电脑上，而不必担心，哦，那个在我的笔记本上。我需要在台式机上用它。
Let me email it to myself or put it in a USB stick or whatever that is. Yeah, this is interesting. This is good stuff. Yeah, it seems like it shouldn't be that hard. They have to kind of hook into the OS, but whenever they see that a certain file has changed in a directory that they're monitoring, they can go and propagate and give that file to everybody else. It's one of those apps that seems kind of straightforward, but then the devil's probably in the details there,
让我发邮件给自己，或者把它放在 U 盘里，或者其他什么。是的，这很有趣。这是好东西。是的，看起来这不应该那么难。他们必须连接到操作系统，但每当他们看到他们正在监控的目录中的某个文件发生了变化，他们就可以去传播并把那个文件给其他人。这似乎是那种看起来很直接的应用程序，但魔鬼可能就在细节中，
especially if you want to make it run on Mac and Windows and Samba. Yeah, reliably. It has to recover. If one of the machines goes down, when it comes back up, it'll have to try to, you know, get him back in sync and all that. Right. Not trivial, but if somebody could do it in an open source package, that'd be awesome. Yeah. Yeah, definitely.
特别是如果你想让它在 Mac、Windows 和 Samba 上运行。是的，可靠地。它必须恢复。如果其中一台机器宕机了，当它重新启动时，它必须尝试，你知道，让它恢复同步等等。对。不容易，但如果有人能在开源包中做到这一点，那就太棒了。是的。是的，绝对。
So, well, is it time for the throwdown of Python? I think so. Let's throw it down. So I guess I'll cover this. So Python is an interpreted language. It is semi-compiled, which means that there is a Python virtual machine similar to Java, and you can compile Python files into bytecode
那么，是时候进行 Python 的对决了吗？我想是的。让我们开始吧。所以我猜我来介绍一下。所以 Python 是一种解释型语言。它是半编译的，这意味着有一个类似于 Java 的 Python 虚拟机，你可以将 Python 文件编译成字节码
for that virtual machine. So in that sense, it can take advantage of compiling. But overall, it's generally interpreted language. And the goal of Python is productivity. So Python boasts a 4x increase in productivity. So in other words, if it takes you four weeks to write some app in C or C++, then in theory you can write it in a week in Python. I assume that would be an experienced Python person could write it in a week in Python. Yeah, oh yeah.
给那个虚拟机。所以从这个意义上说，它可以利用编译。但总的来说，它通常是解释型语言。Python 的目标是生产力。所以 Python 号称生产力提高了 4 倍。换句话说，如果你用 C 或 C++ 写某个应用程序需要四周时间，那么理论上你可以在一周内用 Python 写出来。我假设那是一个有经验的 Python 人员可以在一周内用 Python 写出来。是的，哦，是的。
This doesn't have magical powers, does it? I think it does. I think genies come out and actually plug in little Bluetooth USB keyboards and just write alongside of you as you're writing. What? Where has this been all my life? I know, it Bluetooth USB keyboards and just write alongside of you as you're writing. What? Where has this been all my life? I know it's the genies. They're just, they're there. I think that, yeah, you're right. You have to be experienced in Python. And it's one of those languages that does come with a learning
这没有魔法，对吧？我认为有。我认为精灵会出来，实际上插上蓝牙 USB 键盘，在你写作时就在你旁边写。什么？这东西我一生都在哪里？我知道，蓝牙 USB 键盘，在你写作时就在你旁边写。什么？这东西我一生都在哪里？我知道是精灵。他们只是，他们在那里。我想，是的，你是对的。你必须有 Python 经验。它是那种确实带有学习
curve. One of the big things about a lot of these high level languages like Python is that it gives you a lot of flexibility. But because it does does that you can kind of hang yourself with all the rope that it gives you and so that's why you know having a strong foundation in one of the imperative languages kind of will allow you to sort of remain grounded in your in your architecture even with you know all of the flexibility that Python gives you. So why is it named Python? Oh, that's a great question.
曲线的语言之一。像 Python 这样的许多高级语言的一大特点是它给了你很大的灵活性。但因为它这样做了，你可能会用它给你的所有绳子把自己吊死，所以这就是为什么，你知道，在命令式语言中拥有坚实的基础会让你在架构上保持扎实，即使有，你知道，Python 给你的所有灵活性。那么为什么它叫 Python？哦，这是一个很好的问题。
Do you know the answer to that, or are you just quizzing me? Oh, it's a Monty Python reference. No way. Yep. Oh, wow. I'll have to look that up. No, definitely. So I figure any programming language that uses Monty Python references sprinkled throughout has to be good.
你知道答案，还是只是在考我？哦，这是一个 Monty Python 的梗。不会吧。是的。哦，哇。我得去查查。不，绝对。所以我认为任何在整个过程中穿插 Monty Python 梗的编程语言一定很好。
That's true. Or at least british i don't know oh yep you're right oh what oh hang on theme music theme music where is it you're like you're uh uh that's gonna get saved like that's gonna be dubbed out now whenever we have an argument you're gonna bring that back yeah remember about the python interesting so yeah so let's talk a little bit about more about python it's garbage collected similarly to java so in other words you don't have to you know as you might remember from our c podcast a couple weeks weeks ago. In this case, you don't have to tell the system when to allocate in free memory. You just say, hey, I have this list of data. I have this dictionary and it's a dictionary of phone numbers. And I want the phone number of Joe to be 999999. And
那是真的。或者至少是英国的，我不知道，哦，是的，你是对的，哦，什么，哦，等等，主题音乐，主题音乐，它在哪里？你就像你，呃，呃，那会被保存，就像那现在会被配音，每当我们争论时，你就会把它带回来，是的，记得关于 Python 的事，很有趣，所以是的，让我们多谈谈 Python，它像 Java 一样是垃圾回收的，换句话说，你不必，你知道，正如你可能从我们几周前的 C 语言播客中记得的那样。在这种情况下，你不必告诉系统何时分配和释放内存。你只需要说，嘿，我有这个数据列表。我有这个字典，它是电话号码字典。我想要 Joe 的电话号码是 999999。然后
it automatically decides I'm going to create a dictionary. I'm going to allocate memory for that dictionary. There's a new entry. Maybe I have to increase the size of the dictionary to handle the new entry. It does all of that. So you're completely oblivious to the memory manager. Sounds powerful and dangerous. Yeah, I mean, definitely. If you're working on a system that doesn't have a lot of memory, such as an embedded device,
它会自动决定我要创建一个字典。我要为那个字典分配内存。有一个新条目。也许我必须增加字典的大小来处理新条目。它做了所有这些。所以你完全不知道内存管理器。听起来很强大也很危险。是的，我的意思是，绝对。如果你在一个没有太多内存的系统上工作，比如嵌入式设备，
you have to watch out for running out of memory. And in fact, with Python, this is especially an issue because it has a virtual machine. I believe the virtual machine has a memory limit. So in the case of C++, you can, for the most part, allocate memory and just keep on going, keep on allocating memory. And it'll eventually start putting memory, what's called virtual memory, it'll start creating memory regions on your hard drive. But it'll essentially give you the freedom to do whatever you want. In the case of Python, there's a hard limit in the virtual machine. And if you try and allocate, I don't know, 27 gigs of memory, it's just going to throw up.
你必须小心内存耗尽。事实上，对于 Python 来说，这是一个特别的问题，因为它有一个虚拟机。我相信虚拟机有一个内存限制。所以在 C++ 的情况下，你可以在很大程度上分配内存并继续前进，继续分配内存。它最终会开始放置内存，所谓的虚拟内存，它会开始在你的硬盘上创建内存区域。但它本质上会给你自由去做任何你想做的事。在 Python 的情况下，虚拟机中有一个硬限制。如果你尝试分配，我不知道，27 GB 的内存，它只会崩溃。
It's going to cause an error in the virtual machine. So I see this phrase batteries included. What does that mean? Yeah, so Python comes with the Python standard library. And the Python standard library is actually just extremely massive. So yeah, one module in the library is pickle, which I'll talk about a little later for doing serialization. It has zlib. So if you've ever had a.tar.gz file, if you've ever downloaded one of those off the internet, that's using zlib and Python supports
它会在虚拟机中导致错误。所以我看到了“包含电池”这个短语。那是什么意思？是的，所以 Python 自带 Python 标准库。而 Python 标准库实际上非常庞大。所以是的，库中的一个模块是 pickle，我稍后会谈到它，用于序列化。它有 zlib。所以如果你曾经有一个 .tar.gz 文件，如果你曾经从互联网上下载过其中一个，那就是在使用 zlib，而 Python 支持
that natively. So just let's look at that for example. Let's say you wanted to write a C program that opened a.tar.gz file. Or let's say you wanted to write a C program that opened a.tar.gz file. Or let's say you wanted to write a C program that created one of those. You would have to go grab the Zlib library, compile it along with your code, read up on the API and work your way through that. With Python all that stuff is included. So you don't have to worry about building Zlib and what sort of compile parameters you need to give it and things through that. With Python all that stuff's included so you don't have to worry about building zlib and what sort of you know compile parameters you need to give it and things like that. All that stuff's in there. It has you know
它原生支持。所以让我们看看那个例子。假设你想写一个打开 .tar.gz 文件的 C 程序。或者假设你想写一个打开 .tar.gz 文件的 C 程序。或者假设你想写一个创建其中一个的 C 程序。你必须去获取 Zlib 库，把它和你的代码一起编译，阅读 API 并通过它工作。用 Python，所有这些东西都包含在内了。所以你不必担心构建 Zlib 以及你需要给它什么样的编译参数等等。用 Python，所有这些东西都包含在内了，所以你不必担心构建 zlib 以及你需要给它什么样的，你知道，编译参数等等。所有这些东西都在里面。它有，你知道
comma separated values for writing stuff that could be read by Excel. It's got hashing, just tons JSON encoding and decoding, email handling. It actually the Python standard library has a HTTP web server built into it. So you can host your own website using just Python. So you can get hacked without even needing an extra library. No, I'm just teasing. That's right. You can have your user's email addresses leaked like TripAdvisor did earlier today without anything
逗号分隔值，用于编写可以被 Excel 读取的东西。它有哈希，大量的 JSON 编码和解码，电子邮件处理。它实际上，Python 标准库内置了一个 HTTP 网络服务器。所以你可以只用 Python 托管你自己的网站。所以你甚至不需要额外的库就可以被黑。不，我只是开玩笑。那是对的。你可以像 TripAdvisor 今天早些时候那样泄露用户的电子邮件地址，而不需要任何东西
but Python. So that's cool. That's cool. Now, the fact that it has all these libraries, is there good documentation for those? Yeah. So there's docs.python.org, which is, you know, Python's own documentation system. And that is extremely comprehensive. And I think you've also found a couple of websites that kind of learn Python as well, right? Yeah, so, you know, under the kind of one of our charter goals here is that help people, you know, see the uses of other languages.
除了 Python。所以这很酷。这很酷。现在，它有所有这些库的事实，有好的文档吗？是的。所以有 docs.python.org，这是，你知道，Python 自己的文档系统。而且非常全面。我想你也找到了一些学习 Python 的网站，对吧？是的，所以，你知道，在我们这里的一个章程目标下，是帮助人们，你知道，看到其他语言的用途。
So, for instance, we talk about Python being, helping you be more productive potentially. And so as part of that, you got to learn those languages so that you can exploit the benefits to the fullest. So talk about, you know, a little bit about our experiences, if we have any with learning the language. And one interesting thing, if you've, if you're listening to the show, and you don't yet know any programming languages, I think a lot of people consider Python a good first one to learn. What do you think, Jason? Yeah, definitely. I think that I think Python was one of the goals of Python was to sort of be simple to use and to understand. And it seemed like there was almost an educational focus to Python. And because of that, I think that
所以，例如，我们谈论 Python 是，帮助你潜在地提高生产力。所以作为其中的一部分，你必须学习这些语言，以便你可以充分利用这些好处。所以谈谈，你知道，一点关于我们的经验，如果我们有任何学习这门语言的经验。一件有趣的事情，如果你，如果你正在听这个节目，并且你还不知道任何编程语言，我认为很多人认为 Python 是一个很好的入门语言。你觉得呢，Jason？是的，绝对。我认为，我认为 Python 的目标之一是，你知道，简单易用和理解。而且看起来 Python 几乎有一种教育重点。正因为如此，我认为
yeah, Python would definitely be a great starter language. One of the things that you really have to watch out for in languages like C and C++ are dealing with these sort of these really high level structures and manipulating structures and memory and reading and writing structures to files can be challenging. And so Python obfuscates all of that from you. I mean, you don't really have to deal with a lot of that low-level stuff, and you can get right to doing what you want. I mean, typically, you know, what people want to learn programming so that they can do something, so that they can accomplish something, whether they want to write their own, you know, little
是的，Python 绝对会是一个很好的入门语言。你在像 C 和 C++ 这样的语言中真正需要小心的一件事是处理这些，你知道，这些非常高级的结构，操作结构和内存，以及读取和写入结构到文件可能具有挑战性。所以 Python 为你混淆了所有这些。我的意思是，你真的不必处理很多那种底层的东西，你可以直接做你想做的事。我的意思是，通常，你知道，人们想要学习编程是为了他们可以做某事，为了他们可以完成某事，无论他们是想写自己的，你知道，小
web calendar to keep themselves focused, or whether they want to just kind of make a game or something to entertain themselves and their friends. And you don't want to get bogged down in a lot of the details, especially as a beginning programmer or working on a project by yourself. And so Python really does a lot of that heavy lifting for you, you know, at the expense of being slower than one of the more low-level languages. Yeah, definitely. And so my first kind of learning link that I had here is something I ran across, and of course, already having a fair amount of experience with programming, this was not that helpful to me, but it was really interesting.
网络日历来让自己保持专注，还是他们只是想制作一个游戏或什么东西来娱乐自己和朋友。而且你不想陷入很多细节中，特别是作为一个初学者程序员或独自在一个项目上工作。所以 Python 确实为你做了很多繁重的工作，你知道，以比低级语言慢为代价。是的，绝对。所以我的第一个学习链接在这里是我偶然发现的，当然，已经有了相当多的编程经验，这对我不那么有帮助，但它真的很有趣。
And I believe the guy who started this, but it's kind of a community effort now, I think his name's Zed, Zed Shah, maybe. And he has Learn Python the Hard Way. And we'll include the link in the show notes, but it's learnpythonthehardway.org. And it's kind of interesting. It's a book and it kind of goes through and says, look, this is going to be confusing. When you learn these programs, it's not going to be easy and straightforward. So he kind of starts out by going through stuff that, you know, would have kind of been nice in the, I remember learning, you know, programming kind of on my own without before going to, you know, you know, school for it or having a class on it. And it's, he kind of
我相信开始这个项目的人，但现在这是一种社区努力，我想他的名字叫 Zed，Zed Shah，也许。他有《笨办法学 Python》。我们会在节目笔记中包含链接，但它是 learnpythonthehardway.org。这很有趣。这是一本书，它贯穿其中并说，看，这会让人困惑。当你学习这些程序时，它不会是简单直接的。所以他开始通过经历一些，你知道，在，我记得学习，你知道，编程，你知道，我自己，没有在去，你知道，你知道，学校之前或上课之前。而且它是，他有点
takes you through what I think a lot of people end up doing, which is, you know, type this code in, you're going to make mistakes, but type it in, you know, just copy this code into a thing, don't copy and paste it, type it in, and you're going to begin mistakes, but type it in. You know, just copy this code into a thing. Don't copy and paste it. Type it in. And you're going to begin to kind of understand, become familiar, and intuit what the programs are doing. And then also, that'll kind of, since you've typed it in, you'll kind of lead you to experiment and start trying little things and seeing how it changes or reacts or what breaks. And kind of approaching it from that way, which is an interesting way. I hadn't really, it's a refreshing take on how to learn programming.
带你经历我认为很多人最终会做的事情，也就是，你知道，输入这段代码，你会犯错误，但输入它，你知道，只是把这段代码复制到一个东西里，不要复制和粘贴它，输入它，你会开始犯错误，但输入它。你知道，只是把这段代码复制到一个东西里。不要复制和粘贴它。输入它。你会开始，你知道，理解，变得熟悉，并直觉地知道程序在做什么。然后，那也会，因为你已经输入了它，你会，你知道，引导你去实验并开始尝试一些小事情，看看它如何改变或反应或什么东西坏了。并以那种方式接近它，这是一种有趣的方式。我真的没有，这是一种关于如何学习编程的令人耳目一新的方式。
Yeah, that sounds awesome. I'm definitely going to have to give that a shot. So the other resource I had here is PyCon, which is the big Python conference. I think just recently the 2011 PyCon happened. I think it was in Atlanta. Is that right? Yeah, that's right. And the next one, 2012, is going to be in Santa Clara, California, which is right next to Google, right next to Mountain View. Now, actually, that's a good point. Google uses Python a lot, right?
是的，那听起来太棒了。我肯定得试一试。所以我在这里拥有的另一个资源是 PyCon，这是大型 Python 会议。我想最近 2011 年的 PyCon 刚刚发生。我想是在亚特兰大。对吗？是的，那是对的。下一个，2012 年，将在加利福尼亚州的圣克拉拉举行，就在谷歌旁边，就在山景城旁边。现在，实际上，这是一个很好的观点。谷歌经常使用 Python，对吧？
Yeah. So Google has employed the creator of Python, Guido von Rossum I believe he worked at a number of you know large well-known companies but right now he's he's been employed by Google and Google is definitely taking Python seriously they're one of only two diamond level sponsors of PyCon 2011 and so yeah they Who's the other one? The other one is QNX. I think that's embedded, right? And RTOS, isn't it? Yeah, that's right. Why don't you explain RTOS for a bit?
是的。所以谷歌雇佣了 Python 的创造者，Guido von Rossum，我相信他在许多，你知道，大型知名公司工作过，但现在他，他一直被谷歌雇佣，谷歌绝对是在认真对待 Python，他们是 PyCon 2011 仅有的两个钻石级赞助商之一，所以是的，他们，另一个是谁？另一个是 QNX。我想那是嵌入式的，对吧？还有 RTOS，不是吗？是的，那是对的。你为什么不解释一下 RTOS？
That's totally not related to Python, really. Here, I'll do it really quick. Basically, most people are familiar with OSs, operating systems, like Windows, Linux, OSX, etc. RTOS stands for Real-Time Operating System. And to make a long story short, basically, they operate within certain limitations.
那和 Python 完全没关系，真的。在这里，我会很快地做。基本上，大多数人都熟悉操作系统，像 Windows、Linux、OSX 等等。RTOS 代表实时操作系统。长话短说，基本上，它们在一定的限制内运行。
So in the case of Windows, again, going back to this memory thing that I talked about earlier, if you want to allocate a gig of RAM and you don't have a gig of RAM on your machine, it'll go into virtual memory. So it'll make a space on your hard drive and treat that space as memory. So a real-time operating system has certain limitations, like you cannot do something like that because it would take away from the real-time nature. It just takes too long to do something like that. And so there's many other, it gets complicated, but the basic gist of it is that they're interested in high-performance, low-power operating systems. Interesting. So yeah, actually that gets to an interesting point, which is another lesson of this is it's true that Python has a reputation well suited for being slow. But again, it comes down to how the language is used and a lot of the algorithms that are going into the language.
所以在 Windows 的情况下，回到我之前谈到的这个内存问题，如果你想分配 1 GB 的内存，而你的机器上没有 1 GB 的内存，它会进入虚拟内存。所以它会在你的硬盘上腾出一个空间，并将该空间视为内存。所以实时操作系统有一定的限制，比如你不能做那样的事情，因为它会剥夺实时性。做那样的事情需要太长时间。所以还有许多其他的，它变得复杂，但基本要点是它们对高性能、低功耗操作系统感兴趣。有趣。所以是的，实际上这触及了一个有趣的观点，这是另一个教训，即 Python 的声誉确实适合慢。但同样，它归结为语言的使用方式以及进入语言的许多算法。
So, in other words, you can write some code in Python, someone else who can write the same code in C, and it could be a hundred times slower, just because of the way that you designed your algorithm. Let's say they're constantly creating and deleting arrays. And in your case, you were able to use just one single array. So, you know, a lot of the speed issues can be solved algorithmically or using, you know, a lot of the speed issues can be solved algorithmically or using, you know, being efficient in the way that you allocate and deallocate memory. And, you know, I wouldn't worry too much about Python being, you know, slower than other languages.
换句话说，你可以用 Python 写一些代码，别人可以用 C 写同样的代码，它可能会慢一百倍，仅仅是因为你设计算法的方式。假设他们不断地创建和删除数组。而在你的情况下，你能够只使用一个单一的数组。所以，你知道，许多速度问题可以通过算法解决，或者使用，你知道，许多速度问题可以通过算法解决，或者使用，你知道，在分配和释放内存的方式上保持高效。而且，你知道，我不会太担心 Python 比其他语言慢。
Yeah, I mean, especially for, you know, prototyping or even in full-out production stuff, using it as the scripting aspect. We haven't talked about this yet, but Python integrates really well with C code. Of course, one of the good paradigms to go by in your programming is don't optimize too early. Don't worry about getting your code to run
是的，我的意思是，特别是对于，你知道，原型设计，甚至在全面的生产中，使用它作为脚本方面。我们还没有谈到这个，但 Python 与 C 代码集成得非常好。当然，在你的编程中要遵循的一个好的范例是不要过早优化。不要担心让你的代码运行
fast. Worry about getting it to run first. Donald Newth, one of the founders of computer science, said premature optimization is the root of all evil. So yeah, definitely. And I think that, you know, to sort of extrapolate on that point, you know, the biggest thing I see with like a lot of kind of new or green engineers, is that they'll write some code, it will be slow, and they'll sort of look at things which are somewhat myopic,
快。先担心让它运行起来。计算机科学的创始人之一 Donald Knuth 说，过早优化是万恶之源。所以是的，绝对。而且我认为，你知道，为了，你知道，推断出这一点，你知道，我在很多，你知道，新的或绿色的工程师身上看到的最大事情是，他们会写一些代码，它会很慢，他们会，你知道，看一些有点短视的事情，
like maybe if I do a compiler optimization or if I change languages. But really, there's something fundamentally slow in the algorithm or in the architecture that can give you just a gigantic speedup. Definitely. And being aware of how the computer operates operates which we don't have talked about here yet but i mean understanding at a fundamental level why your computer does what it does how it ticks even down to you know not you have to go that far but that we were talking about and gates and or gates a few minutes ago but i mean understanding a computer at that level helps you write code that uses a computer in the best way possible yeah definitely okay so do you want to talk about oh go ahead
比如也许如果我做一个编译器优化或者如果我换语言。但实际上，算法或架构中存在一些根本性的缓慢，可以给你带来巨大的速度提升。绝对。并且意识到计算机是如何运行的，我们在这里还没有谈到，但我的意思是，在根本层面上理解为什么你的计算机做它所做的事情，它是如何滴答作响的，甚至到，你知道，你不必走那么远，但我们几分钟前谈论的与门和或门，但我的意思是，在那个层面上理解计算机可以帮助你编写以最佳方式使用计算机的代码，是的，绝对。好的，所以你想谈谈，哦，继续
well sorry so so we got in a little bit of a rabbit trail but um so pycon the python conference just finished up in atlanta and um they actually and i i don't know if they posted all of them but they have a lot of videos, recordings of their sessions posted online. And we'll post a link, but it's pi-con.blip.tv. And I've been watching a few of them, and they're actually pretty good quality and really interesting. So, you know, if you've always wanted to go to a conference or never thought about going into a conference, and you look at the topic list and see some interesting things there, go check it out and watch some videos.
好吧，抱歉，所以我们有点跑题了，但是嗯，所以 PyCon，Python 会议刚刚在亚特兰大结束，嗯，他们实际上，我不知道他们是否发布了所有这些，但他们有很多视频，他们会议的录音发布在网上。我们会发布一个链接，但它是 pi-con.blip.tv。我一直在看其中的一些，它们实际上质量相当好，而且非常有趣。所以，你知道，如果你一直想去参加会议，或者从未想过要去参加会议，而你看了主题列表并看到了一些有趣的事情，去看看并观看一些视频。
Most of them are, you know, 30 minutes to an hour in length and talk about everything from everyday parts of Python and panels on what's the best IDE to use for Python all the way to like really, you know, specific optimization, you know, kind of libraries and techniques. Yeah, this gets to kind of a little digression, but I think an interesting point, which is, you know, many of you out there work for, you know, tech companies or maybe IT companies, but work, you know, sort of in the software engineering industry. And, you know,
它们大多数是，你知道，30 分钟到一小时长，谈论从 Python 的日常部分和关于 Python 使用什么最好的 IDE 的小组讨论，一直到像真的，你知道，具体的优化，你知道，那种库和技术。是的，这有点，你知道，有点离题，但我认为是一个有趣的观点，即，你知道，你们中的许多人，你知道，为科技公司或也许 IT 公司工作，但工作，你知道，某种程度上在软件工程行业。而且，你知道，
you should definitely, you know, ask the, you know, your management if they can send you to PyCon or one of these conferences. That's sort of a win-win. Most of the time, most companies have a budget for training, and very often people don't take advantage of the budget, and that money gets wasted. By going to one of these trainings, you can learn a lot about Python or something else, and you also become more valuable. I mean, your employer knows that you've went and gained this skill set
你应该绝对，你知道，问，你知道，你的管理层他们是否可以送你去 PyCon 或这些会议之一。这是一种双赢。大多数时候，大多数公司都有培训预算，而且人们往往不利用预算，钱就被浪费了。通过参加这些培训之一，你可以学到很多关于 Python 或其他东西的知识，而且你也变得更有价值。我的意思是，你的雇主知道你已经去获得了这个技能组合
or you've went and gained some connections with the top people in a certain field or in a certain topic. And that can really help you along further down the road. It's an investment. Yeah, hopefully people's jobs are amenable to those kinds of things. Yeah, definitely. It's an investment. Yeah. Hopefully people's jobs are amenable to those kinds of things. Yeah. It never hurts to ask, right? What are they going to do? Tell you no? Yeah. I mean, worst case, they tell you no. At least, you know, even by asking you, you can, you know, remind them that you're inquisitive. You know, I think that it's useful.
或者你已经去获得了与某个领域或某个主题的顶尖人物的一些联系。这真的可以帮助你走得更远。这是一项投资。是的，希望人们的工作能够适应那种事情。是的，绝对。这是一项投资。是的。希望人们的工作能够适应那种事情。是的。问问从来没有坏处，对吧？他们会做什么？告诉你不行？是的。我的意思是，最坏的情况，他们告诉你不行。至少，你知道，即使通过询问，你也可以，你知道，提醒他们你很好奇。你知道，我认为这很有用。
Yeah, definitely. And I think we could all stand to be told no a little more often. Oh, yeah, that's right. What is it you're trying to, I think your metric was to get told no once a day, right? Yeah. So this was an interesting thing on Hacker News a while ago. I haven't seen anything about it recently. And I don't remember exactly how they phrased it, but it boiled down to this guy came out and said, you know, we assume too much in our lives about restrictions and barriers placed on us and so if you just make it a goal every day to get told no on something anything you know not a silly thing but an actual something get told for real no um that you will learn quickly that people don't we're trained from very young age not to say no to people um so for instance he
是的，绝对。而且我认为我们都可以多被拒绝几次。哦，是的，那是对的。你试图，我想你的指标是每天被拒绝一次，对吧？是的。所以这是 Hacker News 上前段时间的一件有趣的事情。我最近没看到关于它的任何东西。而且我不记得他们确切是怎么说的，但归结为这个家伙出来说，你知道，我们在生活中对强加给我们的限制和障碍假设太多了，所以如果你只是设定一个目标，每天在某事上被拒绝，任何事情，你知道，不是一件愚蠢的事情，而是一件实际的事情，被拒绝，真的不行，嗯，你会很快学到人们不会，我们从很小的时候就被训练不要对人说不，所以例如他
i think one of his examples was he was in some big city and took a cab ride and said, oh, I forgot my wallet, or was getting in the cab and said, oh, I forgot my wallet. Do you mind taking me for free? And the guy's like, oh, okay. You know, just kind of like,
我想他的例子之一是他身处某个大城市，坐出租车，说，哦，我忘了带钱包，或者正在上出租车，说，哦，我忘了带钱包。你介意免费载我一程吗？那个人说，哦，好吧。你知道，只是有点像，
you know, didn't want to tell him no. Or he would wander around areas that looked restricted and people would come up to him and say, what are you doing here? He's like, oh, I don't know. I'm just wandering you doing here he's like oh i don't know i'm just wandering around and he's like you know do i need to leave and they're like kind of um but they had a really hard time telling him like yes you need to leave um so this is amazing yeah so his thing is you know go to your boss and ask you say well no i don't want to be told no they're gonna think i ask too much well go ask because you don't know
你知道，不想告诉他不行。或者他会徘徊在看起来受限制的区域，人们会走过来问他，你在这里做什么？他说，哦，我不知道。我只是徘徊，你在这里做什么，他说，哦，我不知道。我只是徘徊，他说，你知道，我需要离开吗？他们有点，嗯，但他们很难告诉他，是的，你需要离开，所以这太神奇了。是的，所以他的事情是，你知道，去找你的老板问，你说，好吧，不，我不想被拒绝，他们会认为我问得太多，好吧，去问，因为你不知道
like jason pointed out they probably have a budget for it and if that budget's not getting used it'll told no, they're going to think I ask too much. Well, go ask because you don't know. Like Jason pointed out, they probably have a budget for it. And if that budget's not getting used, it'll disappear. So they may in fact be glad to send you to the conference. Yeah, definitely. Okay, let's talk a little bit about virtual machines. Python is kind of interesting in that it actually has several different virtual machines and they all have kind of really unique purposes. So the first and the most common is CPython. Well, hang on. Oh, go ahead.
像 Jason 指出的那样，他们可能有一个预算，如果那个预算没有被使用，它会被拒绝，他们会认为我问得太多。好吧，去问，因为你不知道。像 Jason 指出的那样，他们可能有一个预算。如果那个预算没有被使用，它就会消失。所以他们实际上可能很高兴送你去参加会议。是的，绝对。好的，让我们谈谈虚拟机。Python 有点有趣，因为它实际上有几个不同的虚拟机，它们都有某种非常独特的目的。所以第一个也是最常见的是 CPython。好吧，等等。哦，继续。
So what is a virtual machine? Oh, yeah, this is a good question. So a virtual machine, and I'm probably going to butcher this because I'm not going to work with you. It's okay. I did it twice already this time, so it's your time to sit into the hot seat for a minute. Oh, man, I'm in the hot i'm sweating so the virtual machine a virtual machine is basically a software implementation of you know the fundamental components of a computer
那么什么是虚拟机？哦，是的，这是一个好问题。所以虚拟机，我可能会搞砸这个，因为我不会和你一起工作。没关系。我已经在这个时候做了两次了，所以是你坐在热座上一分钟的时候了。哦，天哪，我在热座上，我在出汗，所以虚拟机，虚拟机基本上是，你知道，计算机基本组件的软件实现
and what that means is essentially a memory space so a a block from which you can allocate chunks of memory, a processor which you can pass instructions to, and a set of registers which you can pass sort of as arguments these instructions to do computation. So let's talk a little bit about an actual machine, about a computer. Basically the way the computer works is you have a bank of memory and we'll just say the memory is indexed by a number. So you can get memory location 0 through 10,000 let's say. And if you want the number that's in memory location 650, you can go and query the memory for that information. Once you get data from memory, it goes into registers, which are locations on the processor
这意味着本质上是一个内存空间，所以一个你可以从中分配内存块的块，一个你可以向其传递指令的处理器，以及一组你可以作为参数传递这些指令来执行计算的寄存器。所以让我们谈谈实际的机器，关于计算机。基本上计算机的工作方式是你有一个内存库，我们只是说内存是由一个数字索引的。所以你可以得到内存位置 0 到 10,000，假设。如果你想要内存位置 650 中的数字，你可以去查询该信息的内存。一旦你从内存中获取数据，它就会进入寄存器，这是处理器上的位置
itself on the chip that hold information. Once you've sort of loaded the registers with information, you can run computations on them. So you can load two registers and then add them together and put the sum of those registers into a third register. That would be an add instruction. The instructions can be simple like that add. They can also be very complicated. So on the VAX machine, there was actually a hardware instruction
本身在芯片上保存信息。一旦你，你知道，用信息加载了寄存器，你就可以对它们运行计算。所以你可以加载两个寄存器，然后把它们加在一起，把这些寄存器的和放入第三个寄存器。那将是一个加法指令。指令可以像那个加法一样简单。它们也可以非常复杂。所以在 VAX 机器上，实际上有一个硬件指令
that would sort a list. So you gave it 16 registers, 16 operators, or 16 parameters, and you gave it the sort instruction. And in hardware, there were physical copper traces that did the sort algorithm for up to 16 elements. So that's the way a real machine works. In the case of a virtual machine, everything is in software. So in other words, the implementation of your instructions,
可以对列表进行排序。所以你给了它 16 个寄存器，16 个操作符，或 16 个参数，你给了它排序指令。在硬件中，有物理铜迹线，为多达 16 个元素执行排序算法。所以这就是真实机器的工作方式。在虚拟机的情况下，一切都在软件中。所以换句话说，你的指令的实现，
let's say you have a sort instruction, the sort is actually done in software. And the sort is actually done by, in this case, using some for loops or whatever, which execute on the actual machine. Your registers are also just locations in memory on the actual machine. Your registers are also just locations in memory on the actual machine so there's no chip in this case because it's virtual and your memory corresponds to memory in the actual machine so that's not too different. So the interesting thing about a virtual machine is that for one thing you can give it any instruction you want you can
假设你有一个排序指令，排序实际上是在软件中完成的。排序实际上是通过，在这种情况下，使用一些 for 循环或任何东西完成的，它们在实际机器上执行。你的寄存器也只是实际机器上内存中的位置。你的寄存器也只是实际机器上内存中的位置，所以这种情况下没有芯片，因为它是虚拟的，你的内存对应于实际机器中的内存，所以这不太不同。所以关于虚拟机的有趣之处在于，一方面你可以给它任何你想要的指令，你可以
make your own instructions because you're not actually doing anything in hardware. You're just composing new instructions from the instructions that already exist on your machine. You can also, you have more error checking. So if you, let's say, do a divide by zero in hardware, that's going to produce some answer i mean the electricity is going to flow through those wires and something's going to happen you're
制作你自己的指令，因为你实际上并没有在硬件中做任何事情。你只是从你机器上已经存在的指令中组合新的指令。你也可以，你有更多的错误检查。所以如果你，假设，在硬件中做一个除以零，那会产生一些答案，我的意思是电流会流过那些电线，会发生一些事情，你
going to get a number so it'll probably actually i think you get a sometimes you get an interrupt oh you can get a divide by zero interrupt usually you get on most os you get a nan yeah so usually you'll get a nan it'll It'll make, there's some specific number. Oh, right, that's right. So there's some specific number that corresponds to not a number, and you'll get that number. On the virtual machine, if you do, you know, a floating point divide by zero or an integer divide by zero,
会得到一个数字，所以它可能会实际上，我想你得到一个有时你会得到一个中断，哦，你可以得到一个除以零中断，通常你在大多数操作系统上得到一个 NaN，是的，所以通常你会得到一个 NaN，它会，有一个特定的数字。哦，对，那是对的。所以有一个特定的数字对应于不是一个数字，你会得到那个数字。在虚拟机上，如果你做，你知道，浮点除以零或整数除以零，
you can crash the virtual machine. But, you know, because the virtual machine is all done in software you're not actually crashing something you know on the hardware level and so it's much easier to debug uh you know one of the bad things about a virtual machine is that it's inherently slower so if you call add uh well that's kind of a bad example because it just calls the machine ad but let's say there's some like let's say there's some instruction called... Foo. Yeah, there's some instruction foo, which actually corresponds to doing 10 ads or something like that.
你可以使虚拟机崩溃。但是，你知道，因为虚拟机完全是在软件中完成的，你实际上并没有使某些东西在硬件级别崩溃，所以调试起来容易得多，你知道，虚拟机的一件坏事是它本质上更慢，所以如果你调用 add，嗯，那是一个糟糕的例子，因为它只是调用机器 add，但假设有一些，假设有一些指令叫... Foo。是的，有一些指令 foo，它实际上对应于做 10 次加法或类似的事情。
Then that instruction is actually going to be quite slow because it's going to actually turn into many different instructions. So... Oh, go ahead. No, no, go. Yeah, so basically a virtual machine sort of gives you a lot of control. You can see exactly what's going on with the system. Since it's all in software, you can take a snapshot. So you can save the state of the virtual machine and then go back. So you can reload your crash over and over again and see exactly how it happened. Interesting. It also provides portability, so running across different actual processors, you can provide the same interface to your program. Yeah, definitely. So
那么那个指令实际上会非常慢，因为它实际上会变成许多不同的指令。所以... 哦，继续。不，不，去吧。是的，所以基本上虚拟机给了你很多控制权。你可以看到系统到底发生了什么。因为它完全在软件中，你可以拍摄快照。所以你可以保存虚拟机的状态，然后回去。所以你可以一次又一次地重新加载你的崩溃，看看它到底是怎么发生的。有趣。它还提供了可移植性，所以跨越不同的实际处理器运行，你可以为你的程序提供相同的接口。是的，绝对。所以
let's say, for one example, if your processor has SSE on it, you might have access to SSE hardware instructions that, you know, someone else doesn't have access to. But in the case of the virtual machine, all of your instructions are in software. So as long as you can compile the virtual machine for your particular computer, you know that you have access to every single instruction. And interesting things, which are another kind of gotcha but you know the virtual machine on the computer with ssc could have ssc acceleration but then you can run on another computer and assume that that's there because those instructions are still there but that acceleration can't happen
举个例子，如果你的处理器支持 SSE 指令集，你可能可以使用别人无法使用的 SSE 硬件指令。但在虚拟机的情况下，你所有的指令都是通过软件实现的。因此，只要你能为你的特定计算机编译虚拟机，你就知道你可以使用每一条指令。还有一些有趣的情况，虽然是另一种陷阱，但你知道，在支持 SSE 的计算机上运行的虚拟机可能具有 SSE 加速功能，但当你换到另一台计算机上运行时，你不能假设它依然存在，因为虽然指令还在，但那种加速效果可能无法实现。
because there isn't a hardware so that has to be done in software right that's right yeah so that's actually interesting the virtual machine can run faster or slower depending on the specs of your actual machine and what instructions are actually there. So what's the difference between a virtual machine and an emulator? Oh, interesting. So that's a good question. Okay, I'll give my opinion. Okay, yeah, you go first. Then you can tell me if I'm right or wrong. Okay. So an emulator, which we haven't talked about, is kind of taking a real-world, and these are generalizations, but taking a real-world device. And so we're talking about the Apple emulator online before the Apple IIe emulator. So taking a real device and creating a program that runs on other hardware typically so for instance in this case a
因为没有相应的硬件，所以必须通过软件来完成，对吧？没错。所以这其实很有趣，虚拟机运行的速度快慢取决于你实际机器的规格以及实际存在的指令。那么虚拟机和模拟器之间有什么区别呢？哦，有意思。这是个好问题。好吧，我说说我的看法。好的，你先说。然后你可以告诉我我说得对不对。好的。那么模拟器，我们之前没谈过，它有点像是取一个现实世界中的设备——这些都是概括性的说法——比如我们之前在网上谈到的 Apple IIe 模拟器。也就是拿一个真实的设备，创建一个能在其他硬件上运行的程序，通常情况下，比如在这个例子中，一个
windows os running on an intel processor and simulating every ask every hardware aspect of the apple 2e that matters so that you could take a program that was written for an apple 2e and without changing anything in that program run it through your emulator and it would know no difference and it would behave the same and the user could interact with it if it's a user interacting kind of machine. Versus a virtual machine can implement essentially a hypothetical machine,
运行在英特尔处理器上的 Windows 操作系统，模拟 Apple 2e 的每一个重要的硬件方面，这样你就可以拿一个为 Apple 2e 编写的程序，在不改变任何内容的情况下，通过你的模拟器运行它，它会感觉不到任何区别，表现也完全一样，如果这是一个需要用户交互的机器，用户也可以与它进行交互。而虚拟机本质上可以实现一个假设的机器，
a machine that doesn't exist in the real world. So Python doesn't implement a virtual machine that is a facsimile of another machine. It could have 1024 registers where no real machine's gonna have that many registers. It could have, in theory, an infinite stack that no hardware could actually have. It can do stuff that isn't possible in real hardware
一个在现实世界中不存在的机器。所以 Python 实现的虚拟机并不是另一台机器的复制品。它可以拥有 1024 个寄存器，而现实中没有任何机器会有那么多寄存器。理论上，它可以拥有任何硬件都无法实现的无限堆栈。它可以做现实硬件中不可能实现的事情，
or even has just never existed in real hardware. And it's not bound to trying to emulate some other kind of hardware just providing a consistent interface to programs that are written for it yeah i think that i think that makes sense i think that you know the point the biggest point there is the uh the fact that you know like you said the emulator is actually emulating another system whereas you know a virtual machine can be completely virtual but i guess fundamentally they're the same though so yeah i don't think that i think a lot of it is connotative you know
或者甚至是现实硬件中从未存在过的东西。它不受限于模拟某种其他硬件，只是为编写在其上的程序提供一个一致的接口。是的，我想这说得通。我认为最重要的一点是，正如你所说，模拟器实际上是在模拟另一个系统，而虚拟机可以是完全虚拟的，但我认为从根本上讲它们是一样的，所以我认为很多区别只是在内涵上。
emulators are typically you know where you're going and trying to emulate a machine uh you know a specific piece of hardware like a nintendo or something whereas a virtual machine is often referred to um you know emulating an operating system, like running Linux inside of Windows using VMware or something like that. Yeah. Or in this case, running a Python machine inside of a Windows or a C-based machine. Yeah, so let's talk a little bit
模拟器通常是你试图模拟一台机器，比如特定的硬件，像任天堂之类的，而虚拟机通常指的是模拟一个操作系统，比如使用 VMware 在 Windows 中运行 Linux 之类的。是的。或者在这个例子中，在 Windows 或基于 C 的机器中运行一个 Python 机器。是的，那么让我们谈谈
about the different Python virtual machines and why they're important. Sorry, I got a little side talk there. No, it's good. It's good.'s good so uh so there's c python which is which is the original python virtual machine and it's as the name suggests coded in c um it uh it's compiled for whatever you know actual machine you're running it on so uh if you're you know on linux you're using a Python virtual machine that was compiled for Linux.
不同的 Python 虚拟机以及它们为什么重要。抱歉，刚才有点跑题了。不，这很好。这很好。所以，有 CPython，它是最初的 Python 虚拟机，顾名思义，它是用 C 语言编写的。它针对你正在运行的任何实际机器进行了编译，所以如果你在 Linux 上，你使用的就是为 Linux 编译的 Python 虚拟机。
And there's a bunch of compile defines to try to use the same code base on many different machines. There's also Stackless Python. And Stackless Python is actually quite interesting. It gives some extensions to Python that make it more multi-core and multi-processor friendly. And do you know, have you ever used Stackless Python? I have not. It has, yeah, it does a lot more for multi-processing types, for parallel processing, right? Yeah, one interesting thing about Stackless Python is it's used by EVE Online, which boasts the largest single online server user base of any multi-user environment.
并且有很多编译定义来尝试在许多不同的机器上使用相同的代码库。还有 Stackless Python。Stackless Python 其实非常有趣。它为 Python 提供了一些扩展，使其对多核和多处理器更加友好。你知道，或者你用过 Stackless Python 吗？我没用过。它确实在多处理类型、并行处理方面做了很多工作，对吧？是的，关于 Stackless Python 有趣的一点是，它被 EVE Online 使用，该游戏拥有任何多用户环境中最大的单一在线服务器用户群。
So I believe there's tens of thousands of people on a single bank of servers that can all potentially interact with each other simultaneously using EVE Online. So World of Warcraft has millions and millions of users, but it's split up into several what's called shards. Actually, sorry, it's split up into several servers, and each server is split up into shards. So what that means is, let's say I might be playing on Server X and Patrick is playing World of Warcraft on server Y. We have no way of really interacting with each other.
所以我相信在单一服务器群上有成千上万的人，他们都可以通过 EVE Online 同时进行潜在的交互。所以魔兽世界有数以百万计的用户，但它被分成几个所谓的“碎片”（shards）。实际上，抱歉，它被分成几个服务器，每个服务器又被分成碎片。这意味着，假设我可能在服务器 X 上玩，而 Patrick 在服务器 Y 上玩魔兽世界。我们真的没有办法进行交互。
We're in completely different universes. And so they're completely disjoint. So you can think of each of those as a completely different game. Then on top of that, different areas of the world of a single server are sharded so if i'm in one area and patrick's in another area of the world we're on different physical servers so in contrast with eve online everyone can be in exactly the same location um at one time all of the users in the entire um game there are no you. There isn't multiple servers. And so they boast that they're able to do this
我们处于完全不同的宇宙中。所以它们是完全分离的。你可以把它们中的每一个都看作是完全不同的游戏。除此之外，单个服务器的世界的不同区域也是分片的，所以如果我在一个区域，而 Patrick 在世界的另一个区域，我们在不同的物理服务器上。相比之下，在 EVE Online 中，每个人都可以同时处于完全相同的位置，游戏中的所有用户都在一起。没有多个服务器。所以他们吹嘘他们能够做到这一点，
because of Stackless Python. So they can have gigantic flash mobs. Yeah, that's right. And there's crazy news stories on the New York Times and other papers on just crazy things that have happened. I think one time one faction, or I think it's called a corporation, went to war on another corporation. And over the span of a few weeks, something like $10,000 or $20,000 of real money, because apparently there's a conversion between real money and EVE Online money. Like $20,000 was lost in this battle.
是因为 Stackless Python。所以他们可以进行巨大的“快闪”活动。是的，没错。而且《纽约时报》和其他报纸上都有关于发生的疯狂事情的疯狂新闻报道。我想有一次一个派系，或者我想它被称为一个公司，向另一个公司宣战。在几周的时间里，大约 1 万到 2 万美元的真钱，因为显然现实货币和 EVE Online 货币之间存在转换。这场战斗中损失了大约 2 万美元。
It's just insane, the magnitude. And so, yeah, Stackless Python works basically by enhancing Python using something called tasklets, which are... Actually, I think in Python they're not called tasklets. I think they're called micro threads. But basically, just to explain it briefly, you know, variables and data, you know, when you're doing programming, you might have access to a certain set of data and you're doing computation. And you might say, okay, I want to sort both of these arrays. There's these very large arrays and I need to sort both of them. What I'm going to do is create two threads. And in the first thread, I'm going to sort the first array.
这太疯狂了，这种规模。所以，是的，Stackless Python 的工作原理基本上是通过使用所谓的“任务集”（tasklets）来增强 Python，它们是……实际上，我认为在 Python 中它们不叫任务集。我想它们被称为微线程。但基本上，简单解释一下，你知道，变量和数据，当你进行编程时，你可能可以访问一组特定的数据并进行计算。你可能会说，好吧，我想对这两个数组进行排序。这里有这些非常大的数组，我需要对它们两个都进行排序。我要做的是创建两个线程。在第一个线程中，我将对第一个数组进行排序。
And in the second thread, I'll sort the second array. And if you have a multi-core CPU, it can do both of those things simultaneously. And that gives you a 2x speedup in time. So Stackless Python has a very high affinity to being able to create threads. Typically, when you create another thread, you have to sort of tell it what variables are yours, what variables are mine, and you have to create what's called a frame for that thread. With Stackless Python, you can create micro threads, which don't have a frame and don't have a context. And because of that, it runs extremely fast.
在第二个线程中，我将对第二个数组进行排序。如果你有一个多核 CPU，它可以同时做这两件事。这会给你带来两倍的时间加速。所以 Stackless Python 在创建线程方面有很高的亲和力。通常，当你创建另一个线程时，你必须告诉它哪些变量是你的，哪些是我的，并且你必须为该线程创建一个所谓的“帧”（frame）。使用 Stackless Python，你可以创建没有帧、没有上下文的微线程。正因为如此，它运行得非常快。
So if you need to create a lot of threads, you can do so very efficiently. So to go back to EVE Online, they might have a thread for every player that's constantly updating the player statistics and things like that. And that architecture is what allows them to scale to those levels. So we got CPython, StacklessPython, any others? Yeah, so there's PyPy, which is a Python virtual machine written in Python. And I always thought that this was sort of an educational thing, something that Python developers can use to learn more about the language. But I'm learning more now that Python, that PyPy actually runs Python code faster than CPython. And it gets really hairy as to why this is, but
所以如果你需要创建大量的线程，你可以非常高效地完成。回到 EVE Online，他们可能为每个玩家都有一个线程，不断更新玩家统计数据之类的。这种架构使他们能够扩展到这些水平。所以我们有 CPython，Stackless Python，还有其他的吗？是的，还有 PyPy，这是一个用 Python 编写的 Python 虚拟机。我一直认为这是一种教育性的东西，是 Python 开发人员可以用来更多地了解该语言的东西。但我现在了解到，PyPy 实际上比 CPython 运行 Python 代码更快。关于为什么会这样，情况变得非常复杂，但
basically it boils down to, again, coming down to these frames. So in CPython, every time you enter a new function, it has to create a new frame. So if you create a new variable inside of a function, it has to know that that variable's with that function. And when you return out of the function, that variable needs to be destroyed. So the set of all variables inside of a function is called a frame. Local variables. Yeah, local variables, that's right.
基本上归结为，再次回到这些帧上。在 CPython 中，每次进入一个新函数，它都必须创建一个新帧。所以如果你在一个函数内部创建一个新变量，它必须知道该变量属于那个函数。当你从函数返回时，该变量需要被销毁。所以函数内部所有变量的集合被称为一个帧。局部变量。是的，局部变量，没错。
So CPython, I guess the frames require a lot of overhead. And as you're calling functions and returning out of functions, you're wasting a lot of time. And PyPy somehow gets around this by using something called virtualizables. So yeah, I still have more to learn there, but it is another Python virtual machine to consider if you're developing in Python and performance is important.
所以 CPython，我想这些帧需要大量的开销。当你调用函数并从函数返回时，你浪费了很多时间。而 PyPy 通过使用所谓的“可虚拟化对象”（virtualizables）以某种方式绕过了这一点。所以是的，我还有很多东西要学，但如果你正在用 Python 开发并且性能很重要，它是另一个值得考虑的 Python 虚拟机。
They also do a number of interesting tricks, which probably we're running a little long in time tonight, so we won't necessarily talk about, but just-in-time compilation and stuff as well, right? Yeah, I mean, just really quickly, the way that kind of works is, you know, computers like absolute numbers. I mean, if you have a loop and you're trying to loop through these items in a list, and you loop from one to the size of the list, but you don't really know what the size is, the size could the list, but you don't really know what the size is. The size could be changing. Computers, you know, they can't optimize that because they don't really know every time
他们还做了一些有趣的技巧，今晚我们可能时间有点长了，所以我们不一定会谈论，但还有即时编译之类的，对吧？是的，我的意思是，简单来说，它的工作方式是，你知道，计算机喜欢绝对的数字。我的意思是，如果你有一个循环，并且你试图遍历列表中的这些项目，并且你从 1 循环到列表的大小，但你并不真正知道大小是多少，大小可能会改变。计算机，你知道，它们无法优化这一点，因为它们并不真正知道每次
they go through this loop, they don't know if this is going to be the last time or not. What Adjust In Time Compiler does is it's able to say, okay, I know that the size isn't going to change in the next millisecond, so I'm going to lock that down, and I'm going to tell the system, the actual machine, that I'm looping from 1 to 30 instead of from 1 to the size of the list. And so because of just-in-time compilation and being able to limit what things are changing and at what times, the actual machine is able to run much faster.
它们执行这个循环时，它们不知道这是否是最后一次。即时编译器（Just-In-Time Compiler）所做的是它能够说，好吧，我知道大小在下一毫秒内不会改变，所以我将锁定它，并且我将告诉系统，即实际机器，我正在从 1 循环到 30，而不是从 1 循环到列表的大小。因此，由于即时编译以及能够限制哪些事物在什么时间发生变化，实际机器能够运行得快得多。
Interesting, interesting. Good stuff. Yeah. Do you have anything else to add on Python? So much stuff to add, I'm sure. But I think we covered it fairly well. I mean, at least at an introductory level slash deep level, we've kind of been bouncing around a little. But I think that's good. It'll cover all parts of our audience. Yeah, I think that people who are just learning python or learning programming for the first time
有趣，有趣。好东西。是的。关于 Python 你还有什么要补充的吗？肯定有很多东西要补充。但我认为我们已经涵盖得相当不错了。我的意思是，至少在入门级到深入级，我们一直在跳跃。但我认为这很好。它将覆盖我们所有的听众。是的，我认为那些刚开始学习 Python 或第一次学习编程的人
can sort of go back later and learn more about you know virtual machines and things like that um by you know listening to this podcast a second time and people who are you know really experts can uh hopefully uh learn one or two things from from uh from us today definitely and i'd be happy if they listened to it once. We'll worry about them listening to it the second time later. Let's get enough people listening to it the first time. Yeah, that's right. So on that, I guess as a conclusion,
可以稍后再回来了解更多关于虚拟机之类的事情，通过第二次收听这个播客，而那些真正是专家的人，希望今天能从我们这里学到一两件事。当然，如果他们听了一次，我会很高兴。我们会担心他们第二次收听的问题。让我们先让足够多的人第一次收听。是的，没错。所以关于这一点，我想作为总结，
I don't know if you're listening to this, you probably found us on either our website or on iTunes, but we are now on iTunes. So that's a little bit of a yay. Yeah, that's awesome. And we're starting to get a few comments and ratings in. So if you like what you hear, or if you don't remember, Jason said, how, if you think we're terrible, just give us a five-star rating and make us feel so bad
我不知道你是在哪里听到这个的，你可能是在我们的网站或 iTunes 上找到我们的，但我们现在在 iTunes 上了。所以这有点值得高兴。是的，这太棒了。我们开始收到一些评论和评分了。所以如果你喜欢你听到的内容，或者如果你不记得了，Jason 说过，如果你认为我们很糟糕，只要给我们一个五星好评，让我们感觉非常糟糕，
that you think that we're terrible. And yet you still gave us a five-star rating. That's right. And if you liked us, give us a five-star rating and tell us how great we did. Yeah. Yeah, definitely. And if, you know, if you a five-star rating and tell us how great we did. Yeah, yeah, definitely. And if you have any comments, you can email us, programmingthrowdown at gmail.com. Or you can post on our blog, programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com. Yeah, absolutely. In all fairness, we really would like to have any sort of criticisms you guys have, constructive or otherwise, just so that we can try to make this better. We're doing this to help you guys and and to have a great time yeah definitely okay so i guess i guess that wraps this one up unless you have anything else all right so that's us signing off
以至于你认为我们很糟糕。但你还是给了我们五星好评。没错。如果你喜欢我们，给我们一个五星好评，告诉我们我们做得有多好。是的。是的，绝对的。如果你有任何评论，你可以发电子邮件给我们，programmingthrowdown@gmail.com。或者你可以在我们的博客上发帖，programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com。是的，绝对的。公平地说，我们真的很想得到你们的任何批评，建设性的或其他方面的，这样我们就可以尝试让它变得更好。我们这样做是为了帮助你们，并且玩得开心。是的，绝对的。好吧，我想这就结束了，除非你还有什么要说的。好的，那么我们签退了。
see you guys later bye the intro music is axo by biner Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I, and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下次见，再见。片头音乐是 biner 的 axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。